Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Sorry, uh, for being a little bit late, but it's okay.
I'm not the- whoa.
What the fuck?
There's an in- There's in-game music?
Oh, that was the game.
Okay, that like freaked me out.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
That- that's the in-game music.
Okay.
Oh my god, that- that actually freaked me out.
Uh- Anyway, I know I'm not late because there's one, two, three, four people missing.
And one of them is on my team, so...
So, um, I know I'm not late, so- Oh, there's a practice arena?
What the fuck do you mean there's a practice-
Okay.
All right, that's cool.
Oh, that's- I- If I knew there was a practice arena, I would have practiced!
Okay, anyway.
Because there wasn't in the last block wars.
There was no practice arena in the last block wars.
So how the fuck was I supposed to know there was one in this one?
Because I'm just saying, guys.
I remembered I was like asked like during the very first block wars.
I was like, hey, how do I practice for block wars?
And they're like, oh, there's no practice arena.
And then I was like, okay, and now you're telling me there was a practice arena?
Okay, that's cool.
I'm not mad, I'm just disappointed.
I didn't ask for this one because I assumed- I assumed they were all the same!
It's a deep end.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Um, if I have to choose between watching doki or breki for- You chose correctly.
The deep end.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
I don't know.
I just assumed that they're all the same.
How was I supposed to know that this time it'd be different?
Like, what do you mean there's a hub navigation now?
Anyway, um, I'm not lazy.
We're missing literally like number seven is missing two players.
I'm not late, I'm actually not late.
They're not even- I can see who's logged in!
Okay, yeah, there is.
I'm pretty sure music and sound turn this off whether- That's not it.
I did it.
Oh, okay.
This has to be the music.
Oh, sorry, was that really loud?
Did you all- Did you all fucking- Were you all like trying- trying so hard to figure out what the fuck I was saying?
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize how loud it was.
Um, but I'll join the VC later.
I just want to talk.
Um, but, uh, yeah.
Anyway, um, silence.
Anyway, uh, what was I gonna say?
Uh, yeah, dad is officially, uh, um, at the sitter.
Doki Amber Doge is officially at the sitter because, you know, I have to go away, uh, out of Canada to practice for the concert.
Um, so what the fuck is that?
Okay, what?
Oh, sorry, I had to like comprehend what that skin was for a second.
I- Anyway, so I like how this is like an entirely new map for this one.
I wonder if it's like- Oh, I guess because this is not Halloween.
It's like the- I wonder if that's like the normal block wars map.
Anyway, uh, so, um, it was very expensive.
I forgot how expensive.
Because like usually I would put the dog- put him at a dog sitter for like, you know, two to three days.
But this time I'll be gone for a little while, uh, like till like almost like the end of the week.
So I was like- Okay, so I was- when I saw the bill I was like-
Anyway, um, today's gonna be a, uh, really packed day because today, uh, today I have- Oh my gosh, I'm gonna be late for my dance lessons.
That's for sure.
Uh, today is, uh, this.
This block war stream which could last two to three hours.
I don't know if I'll be watching till the very end of the fucking block wars.
Like if we don't make it to the finals.
I don't know.
We'll see.
We'll see how I feel.
Well, because, um, because like I have dance lessons right after.
So, uh, I don't think we're gonna make it to the finals.
You wanna know why?
Because remember that guy, that Feinberg guy that literally single-handedly carried this entire team?
Yeah, he's- he's in here.
Um, I was told this was a rookies- I guess like rookies division.
So, uh, you know the guy that basically had like 80% of the points for our- for our team?
He's on an enemy team.
So, and then we have the project leader who was lagging last time.
I mean, he was a- he was a good player.
But we can't deny the fact that he was lagging at the last tournament.
And, um, um, anyway, so he's- I think each team has like one Minecraft pro.
And then, um, uh, and then, you know, they- they basically- each team has one Minecraft pro.
And then they, um, uh, and then they all like divide it up onto each team and stuff.
So, like, I don't know.
I feel like if Feinberg is gonna be in this tournament, like, they should just remove a player.
I mean, technically he doesn't have the last player.
But like, in my opinion, I think if you remove a player on his team, it'd still be very fair.
It's so- it's so- after what I saw he did last tournament, I feel like it'd be so fair.
That's a compliment.
I'm saying he's literally really good.
Because the last tournament, he basically got us 80% of our points to help us win.
But of course, I clutched the finals though.
Don't forget that.
I- I clutched the finals though.
I- I did that.
No, it's just a for fun thing.
Um, so yeah, I'm- I'm Luigi.
We're all Luigi because we're green.
Uh, but we're just- we're just waiting on people.
I'll join the VC later.
I just wanted to chill and hang out with you guys before.
Also, like, I'm tired.
So like, I need to like, you know, like a slow engine rev to be like, um, to be like social.
To be like an actual- to protect- to fake it.
Fake being an extrovert- extrovert.
Because it's really crazy.
A lot of people think I'm an extrovert, but I'm like so fucking, um, introvert.
No, I'm very tired right now.
I'm waiting for the gamer subs to kick in.
Um, so I'm like revving up, uh, to like pretend to be an extrovert because I'm actually an introvert.
And like, uh, social interaction is very scary.
Um, and today I'm like extra tired, uh, because yesterday was a very long day.
The day before that was a very long day.
And the day before that was also a very long day.
So today is- today is going to be a very long day because today I have this, then dance classes, then member stream, then- then the- then Kamifuro convention with a panel and a meet and greet.
So- and then- and then the day after that, I have a three hour dance lesson.
I think it's like three or four hour dance lessons the day after that.
And I might do a gorilla rush stream because I feel bad because I have a drop.
And then like, obviously, it's very hard to do.
Um, so I keep pressing R.
I keep pressing R.
And then so like, uh, and I have to- and I have to make sure I stream enough of the rush drops before I, uh, before I go leave Canada.
But- and then- and then I'll be in America.
And then I'll be in America practicing for the concert.
And I'll be back at the end of the- at the end of next week.
I have slept just not as much as I would like because, um, okay, is everybody- no, and not everybody's still not here.
All right, we're still missing two more- wait, I'm looking at the VC.
Yeah, we're still missing, uh, two more.
And I'm okay to be- it's okay this week for me to be really busy because- Also, I'm definitely gonna be late for dance classes because like, I went in assuming that like, we're starting at, uh, 11 a.m.
Silly me, we don't- of course we don't start at 11 a.m.
There's like, so many VTubers.
It's like- it's like the VTuber curse you never- It's like the- sorry, VTuber curse you never start on time.
So like, ah, silly me for thinking we're gonna start on time.
If we add up all the VTubers together, we're definitely not starting on time.
Anyway.
I keep pressing R accidentally because I- I'm like, reloading.
You know, I just wanna be like, real- reloading.
What was I gonna say?
Okay, I'm gonna be playing this without the shaders.
Why?
Because I have a feeling- Actually, no, I should like the shaders.
No, I'm gonna do it.
Fuck it, I'm gonna play with the shaders because it looks prettier.
But if I played it without my shaders, this is what it's gonna look like.
I don't know if you guys remember what Minecraft looks like without shaders.
Oh my god, it's so fucking ugly.
No, I decided that like, fuck optimal- optimizing.
If we like, get to the finals, it will be a very pleasant surprise.
It'll be an incredibly pleasant surprise.
Oh my god,
I'm reloading again!
Fuck, okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I keep- I don't know why, I keep wanna reload.
I keep- I need to like, unbind.
I'm gonna unbind the R.
I keep wanting to be like, reload.
Uh, keep binds where the fuck is R.
Um, all right, uh...
No.
No, um, how do I delete it?
How do I delete it?
Wait, how do I delete this?
Is it escape?
All right, good, okay.
All right, that should be good.
Okay, nice, all right.
Okay, are we all here?
No.
No, we're missing one person on our team.
No more reloading.
Okay, okay, let's see, I'm- Oh wait, no, everybody is technically in the VC.
All right, guys, we're gonna pretend we're- we're a real person today.
We're gonna pretend we're- we're real.
We can- we can function in society.
All right, it's skinwalking time.
All right, okay, it's also like more unnerving because there's people I actually don't know.
Like a lot of people I don't know this time around.
So like, like Gumi's not here too.
So it's like, um, it's more unnerving because you can be like, Oh, but Hakko was in your Wrestle- Yeah, but we never really interacted outside of that.
So it's more like everybody is like super new.
Like, I just don't know anybody.
And you're like, oh, but you had that Wolfiez guy.
Yeah, that was the last- that was the only time we've interacted.
The only time we've interacted.
So it's like this entire team is just new.
And I'm like, oh, new!
My entire team is all new people.
And oh, and anxiety goes up.
All right, oh, everybody's here except for- Oh my god, remember when I said they should just remove a player on his team?
I didn't actually mean that, but like, it's a nice surprise.
Just for the fact that like, he's just not there.
Like, it's just a pleasant surprise.
Oh, no, no, he's in the VC.
He's in the VC, so he's gonna come in.
All right, guys, I'm gonna pretend I'm a person now.
Hello?
True, true, true.
It's okay.
I am also- I am fortunately, unfortunately a fanboy too.
So it could be like that.
That's the life I chose.
Wait, is everybody a fanboy here?
What?
Yeah, especially Donkey, dude.
What did I do?
What?
What was my favorite fanboy?
I was like, hyping myself.
I was like, it's time to be social right now.
And then the first thing I heard is everybody's a fanboy.
What the fuck happened in this Discord?
We're just bonding, bro.
You fucking missed out.
Oh my god, thank god I missed out.
Thank god.
You should leave.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm about to open a window of HuniePop right now on YouTube.
But we're gonna like, simulplay it, bro.
It's gonna be crazy.
I'm so lost.
I'm gonna be so for real.
It's okay, dude.
Don't worry about it.
Oh god.
Yeah, whatever.
Yeah, no, that's... yep.
Yep.
I forgot.
That's what you get for fucking inviting YouTubers to your event, bro.
It's on you.
Benzoin, I have a question.
Call me Haka, don't call me Banzai.
I can't.
I need advice.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
I've already disassociated.
Maybe.
I've already like, disassociated from this conversation.
I used to when I was a very angsty teenager.
But not anymore, though.
Because I kind of got too tired of like, having shit in my mouth, if that makes sense.
What the fuck am I hearing?
What's a snake bite?
It's like the... it's the piercings.
Like, little two dots in your... yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need to fix this.
I had them when I was a really angsty teenager.
But then I just became Adam Sandler.
My mouth...
What the hell is that?
Oh my god.
You're so done already.
What, you good?
Okay, I'm fixing my Discord over there.
Bro, it's just snake bites.
What does that tell you?
Like, where else would it be?
Yeah, I said it, Demi.
More like, dummy.
Shut the fuck up, man.
Shut the fuck up, shut the fuck up.
You fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy.
Yeah, fuck that guy, bro.
All right, hold on.
We gotta... we gotta wait for Spleef, all right?
Get his ass.
We have multiple oppositions in this event.
Number one, Booster.
Oh god.
Oh, Demi's gone.
Dude, now you see the names.
Now you see the names.
I have my number one op here.
Fucking Giga, dude.
It's so over the moment.
Giga gets my ass.
I don't know what to do, man.
The Discord is loud?
Okay, I'll turn it down.
Give me my number one op, Haka.
Oh my god.
Maybe I need more gamersubs.
My energy is not to this point yet.
I'm a freak, man.
You can't do that shit to me, bro.
My energy is not to that...
I'm fucking pretty pushed to talk.
My energy is not at that level.
You've been locked into this, dude.
We have a conflict of interest on this, you all right?
Because Giga was our teammates for me and Doki last time and we won.
Pushed to talk needs permission?
Yeah, we won.
It's okay, though.
It's okay.
Okay, guys.
Pushed to talk needs fucking permission.
We got fucking, like, luck-worst winner here.
Like, lying, bro.
We're so fucking ready.
Like, yeah.
We're fucking worrying about it.
You need permission?
Did you push to talk in this server?
We're so fucking ready, bro.
Okay.
And they got me the special fucking hire?
Like, that's fucking crazy, dude.
It's like fucking, like, you know, Cristiano Ronaldo just fucking, like, they just got, like, fucking messy up, like, Minecraft here.
That's just...
Okay.
Where's the mute?
I need to mute myself.
Toggle mute.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Should I speak more Spanish?
Control shift M...
How do I...
I don't know why you're buying this.
I do not know your Spanish.
Save a bind.
Keep it...
I don't know how to say this.
Add a key bind.
It's okay.
Action.
Don't worry, boss.
Toggle mute.
I don't think...
Okay.
Son of a bitch.
Record.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah, I like this guy.
I think they're like a very...
I did it.
I fucking...
Yeah, we're so fucking ready, bro.
I did it.
I figured it out.
I'm gonna mess up.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna mess up the toggle mute.
I know.
I think that was pretty good.
Okay, bring down a Haka.
Okay.
I brought...
You'll be mesmerized by my gamer skills.
I brought him down and then I'll raise up.
All right.
I mean, there's even Shadow the Hedgehog.
We're so fucking ready.
What the fuck?
Nah, he sucks ass.
We'll be in.
Okay.
It's easy.
Everything sucks ass.
Okay, I get it.
Okay, I was gonna be like, what the fuck?
That's not what he looks like.
You play CS, right?
They're still quite...
That's like condescending nowadays.
Wait, oh no, do not...
Wait.
Nah, you're right.
Thank you.
No.
No, I hope I don't make it to the finals.
I can't do this again.
They're like, oh, you guys play CS?
And I'm like, wait a minute.
Wow, you're the one good.
Oh, I can't.
I can't do this again.
I can't do this.
This is basically what we played.
I'm like, so not good.
I can't, I don't...
Not again.
I might have like a plaid leg or like...
Wait, it's really the same.
It's the same games.
Wait.
I won't fuck up this one this time, guys.
Yeah, I think I would rather keep my sanity.
I'm gonna stick to more, you know, like competitive games like fucking Minecraft.
Yeah, I won't fuck it up this time.
Yeah, become a Minecraft streamer like Wolfy, bro.
It's gonna be crazy.
I thought it'd be different.
Kumi told me it was different last time when she played.
This was...
This was a different last time.
See, that's how much I haven't done shit.
CSGO is just a better name.
She told me the last time she was in Blog Wars, it was different.
Yeah, it was cool.
Fuck me for saying every game is gonna be different.
It's literally the same.
Do I get to catch out of the skin and keep the money?
Because it's the same game, I should have experience, right?
I should be able to do this.
I already got a crippling addiction.
It's called fucking Pokemon TCG pocket, man.
It's fucking crazy.
I am actively resisting the urge to play that game.
No, you should play it, dude.
No, no.
Okay.
It got so good to your soul.
I was up at 3 fucking a.m.
pulling like a motherfucker.
Literally doing all the missions and shit.
I got 120 hourglasses and I did my first 10x pack opening.
It was crazy, bro.
I'm telling you, the pulls I'm getting are fucking insane.
I can't wait for this shit to actually get monetized.
I can sell that shit online.
I'd go crazy.
You know, like, how I feel in this...
It's crazy, man.
It's so good.
You know how I feel in this desperate at the moment?
Yeah, you gotta look at it that way.
Okay, the big dogs are like tired of life at that point.
Because they're like everything...
They're just like life.
It's really fun, though.
It's really, really fun.
Like genuinely, I've never been familiar with trading card games like rules and shit.
I just collected them for the art.
But now I know how the game actually fucking works.
And that is like actually really fucking cool.
Because I never thought I was like going to like familiarize myself with the rules and shit.
That's pretty cool.
No, we're gonna socialize.
I'm just...
I need to...
100 % card games.
I just need to like get revved up at the moment.
Hey, me either, though.
But this shit literally gets you in.
It's good.
Like I'm not even kidding you.
I need a guide.
Never in my fucking life I thought I was going to be like studying meta fucking like decks for like Pokemon.
There you go.
I put them back all the way to 100.
I'm telling you, like it's crazy.
Sorry, guys.
I still...
Oh my god.
We're all here.
We're actually all here.
I knew...
I knew I wouldn't be the last.
I was like...
Oh, I'm gonna be like, you know, five minutes late to the server.
But then I'm like, no, that's early.
Yes, FW is even earlier.
Oh, yeah.
That's early, technically.
Oh my god.
Yes!
I was like, I'm gonna go.
Oh my god.
We're actually starting.
Thank god.
We're starting.
No!
Oh my god.
I was practicing in my literature.
Only half an hour late.
Hey, at least you didn't blame the event.
Right, guys?
It's totally...
Aren't you the project leader?
I'm gonna fucking write a complaint right now.
I'm just saying, man.
You're literally the project leader.
People went, oh, actually, I can't play five minutes.
You should be like...
If you're late, you get a warning.
And if you get three warnings, you're kicked out of FW never again.
I've been sitting...
Hey, not me, not me, not me anymore.
Heavenly father.
Let's go.
All right.
I've been sitting here for a fucking hour.
You guys literally came here like 10 minutes before the stream actually happened.
But you guys were too busy talking to your chat and shit.
Hey, Wolf, can you not make that rule?
Oh, so you don't like your chat because you don't want to talk to your chat.
That's fucked.
You don't like...
Oh, my God.
You don't like your chat.
You don't want to talk to them.
You're trying to find excuses to not talk to them.
I love these motherfuckers.
I would fucking die for them.
But what happens?
I'm not like...
Oh, but you're like...
Oh, but you're too busy talking to your chat.
Bro, I'm too busy being a fucking idol.
What do you mean?
Like, man, I cannot sit down and just fucking open TikTok like you motherfuckers.
Like, if I could do that, I could be like the whole fucking day.
What the fuck?
I'm streaming on YouTube too.
What the fuck are you talking about?
I follow the same rules as you.
What do you mean?
I went through the same thing.
I gotta get open and all this shit on stream.
Why would you know that?
I'm on YouTube.
I can get demonetized too.
Just log in, bro.
Just log in.
I'm not even on Twitch.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Just log in.
Log in and you'll be fine.
That's like you, bro.
I'm just like, what the fuck is he talking about?
I can't just open TikTok.
What do you mean?
Bro, I'm so dizzy already.
What the fuck's happening?
Who's moving me?
Okay.
Camera on that.
What the fuck?
What did he call you?
Oh, you opened TikTok.
What the fuck do you mean?
Who watched the video?
Okay.
I voiced it.
Oh, for real?
Yeah.
Oh, you did.
All right.
Oh, it seems.
Okay.
I need to bring down Wolf and bring up.
Bring down Wolf.
Can I be your official Spanish dub?
And then them.
Okay.
I brought them up.
They look crazy.
Oh, insane, bro.
I don't even have to look at this.
They're the same thing.
Wow, they're coming.
Boom.
Azaka's still alive.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I brought him to fucking a hundred.
He's going to be lower than a hundred if this keeps up.
Get away from here.
Oh, ew.
I have to die.
That's nasty.
All right.
I brought him down.
Azaka's literally so fucking low right now.
Someone in my chat just said, Lenchu, why are you hock toying?
Okay, I'm back.
Oh, God.
No.
Oh, my God.
Mikey, you're banned.
I'm sorry.
Oh, what is the average age?
Game intro time.
Guys, this is going to be us in approximately three teams.
Oh, God.
How do you know this?
Are you counting?
Oh, it's an order.
Yeah, that's why.
He's literally the leader.
Sorry, guys.
My bad.
Can you tell us the secrets?
Like, what's the best thing?
Um...
Alt-F4 to win.
All right.
I'll do it.
I'm going to do it.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
It's us.
Let's go.
Oh, ew.
Booster.
Oh.
Yeah, this one is more...
Target Booster.
This is like a...
Um...
This is like the rookie division.
But I call bullshit.
It's funny.
He's also going to have to deal with...
I think we should target him during the split.
All I'm saying is...
I won the last one.
So why am I in the rookie division?
But they asked me to play again.
And I was like, all right, sure.
Not knowing my schedule for this week.
And I felt bad.
I was like, I don't want to drop out.
Because I said yes like two weeks ago.
Before I knew what my schedule was going to be like.
For this week.
So I was just like...
Wait, when was the last...
Whenever the last...
Block Wars was...
Whenever the last Block Wars was...
Um...
It was literally right after the last Block Wars.
They asked me if I wanted to do it.
I gave them a day to think about it.
And I was just like, all right, cool, yeah, sure.
And then...
I found out what my schedule was going to be for this week.
And I was like, what?
I'm getting drowned out by everyone else.
Okay, sound guy, what do I need to do?
Next time, I'm winning, right?
I'm so fucking ready.
Wait, people are killing people?
Holy shit, you can kill people?
I can leash someone.
That's fucking right, get off.
Get off of here.
Holy shit, the music is so fucking loud.
Damn.
Dude, I don't hear music.
I literally play my own fucking BGM because I can't hear shit.
Oh, it's in the...
You have to turn it off, I think.
All right.
Okay, everyone is just naturally noisy.
Wait, where are we playing?
What is this?
Is the order up again?
I think I might actually...
What is this?
Oh, it's the dark and dark.
Wait, is this dark and darker?
No, this is order up.
Oh, order up, okay.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
So I'll just gather stuff again.
This is the one that requires...
Wait, no, what?
Is this dark and darker?
Yeah, it's like Tomb Titan.
I'm pretty sure that's not order up.
I didn't look at the screen.
What the fuck is dark and darker?
I want the cool BGM.
I want to hear the cool BGM.
In options, music and sounds, there should be sliders there called hot music and game music.
It's at 100, I don't hear shit.
Oh, I don't think he downloaded the resource pack when he logged in.
I did not!
I don't think he sees anything then.
Like, he can't see anything at all.
I didn't get pinged in the resource pack.
No, when you log in, it tells you to install it.
Maybe just re-log in, you know?
Really?
I didn't get anything.
We'll take care of it.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
No, you will not see anything.
You're going to accidentally run into a fucking mob.
Everything is super customized and everything.
Is Feinberg in this game?
Yes.
Stop the event for me.
I'm going to re-log in.
All I'm saying is that you should have just removed the player in Feinberg's team after what he did last Black Wars.
You should have just removed yourself.
Who's bad Feinberg?
Or just remove all the Minecraft players.
Like the actual Minecraft players.
Just went straight up all rookies.
No Minecraft pros at all.
None of them.
We all try to figure this out ourselves.
I think Feinberg is way too good.
Log off the server, then when you have the server, edit and then enable resource pack.
Wait, do they know?
Do they know to pause?
You guys are waiting for me?
Yes, yes.
Leave the server right now.
I have to fucking hide it.
I thought the server is whitelisted.
Did you edit it?
Yeah, it's downloading.
Sweet, what the fuck?
Yo, nice mustache.
Appreciate that dog.
I was going to give everybody this nose.
I did Demi's first and it looked really weird, so I was like, nevermind.
Oh, but you look so good!
Oh my god!
This would have been so good!
Now we just look like fucking cosplayers instead of actually Luigi.
We look like spirit Halloween costumes.
I do not want to pause the event to give you all a nose and a mustache.
Pause the event!
Pause it!
Let's go.
Okay, so what we did last time is we went in squads.
Wait, but like Feinberg was by himself though.
Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, what we do is if you have experience you can do like a little...
Are you lagging?
Not anymore?
Okay, that's good.
I live in the Philippines so like this fucking server is from the US, right?
Yeah, it might be a little bit.
Wait, is there friendly fire?
Like, can I actually kill someone?
No, no, no, you can just keep fucking swinging.
Just keep swinging.
Fuck it up, fuck it up, fuck it up!
I'm just grabbing stuff.
Wait, you're actually like...
Oh shit, you can actually like loot stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the whole point is dark and dark.
It's literally dark and dark.
Loot as much as you can.
Green candles is a puzzle.
I'm in a puzzle room right now.
Wait, do you actually want a quick explanation?
Haka.
Whoa, what the fuck?
Do you want a quick explanation?
Have you ever played dark and dark, Haka?
It's literally sad in Minecraft form.
Has Haka played dark and dark before?
Yes, I have!
Okay, so yeah, it's just that.
Okay, okay, okay.
Spiders, spiders, spiders.
Oh, you said explanation, not inflation.
Okay, my bad, my bad.
Bro, sorry!
I think if I press this button, we die.
Press the button.
No, you press it.
Okay, fine, I'll press it.
Oh, okay.
Because last time we pressed the button we both fell through a fucking hole!
We did, we actually did.
Wait, should we kill him?
Hey dad, don't die, don't die.
Eat food, drink.
Where's the...
Okay, I did a puzzle.
Okay, I'm lost.
I can't see my map.
Oh, is it my resource pack?
I'm turning off my shader pack.
Are you using your shaders?
Oh, okay.
You know what, fuck it.
Yeah, we're gonna figure it out.
You said poison!
Oh, there's coins here.
Yeah, it's my shader pack.
How is this...
How is this darker than before?
This is actually darker.
Wait, guys, is that...
Do you have your brightness up or do you want to turn that up?
How do we turn it up?
I think if you put your torches in your op hand and you just carry the map it should be better.
I can't believe it, it's actually...
They made it darker!
I can't believe they made it actually darker and darker.
It was lighter before when I first played it.
It's very bright for me.
I can see.
We just said that.
I think the music is piling up for me.
I'm hearing two different songs going on.
No, I do too.
The hub music is going on on top of the darker and darker music.
There's a slider in the sound setting that says turn this off.
You should probably turn that off.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
We don't need hub music.
It says turn off.
I was like, what the fuck is this time signature?
Wait, is there fall damage?
We're gonna try to find out.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
You're all together.
I'm so far behind.
Hold on.
Let me get there real quick.
Fuck him up, fuck him up.
I'm okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Fuck yeah.
I have gold boost for you.
Like, are gold boosts stronger?
Yeah, than like leather?
Yeah, than leather.
How about chainmail?
Which is stronger, chainmail or the gold?
We got a professional Minecraft streamer here.
We forget that shit.
Do you guys actually change to the armor that you want?
I leave.
Goodbye, everybody.
I shall leave now.
Wait, the whole dungeon?
Fuck, okay.
What is this?
Yeah, this is a...
This dungeon is shared with everybody.
But you don't fight any...
You can't fight anybody until you go to like a specific area.
Yeah, but you don't... You can't kill anybody until you go to a specific area.
Fuck this guy up.
Here, here.
I haven't found a single porter.
This is a good legger.
Someone's been here.
What is the point of blocking if it's not even actually blocking?
Okay.
You're blocking because you're playing block wars, you know?
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
Damn.
You know, in my country we kill people for saying shit like that.
I'm gonna die.
Hold on, let me...
I'm so lost, I'm gonna be so for real.
Oh, hello.
I'm gaming.
We're so fucked, dammit.
Oh god, oh god.
Pile up, pile up, pile up.
Wait, are you guys dying?
We're literally getting like destroyed by like five people at the same time.
Wait, do you guys need help?
No, we're winning.
Oh, we're so back, dammit.
Holy shit.
Goddamn.
Wait, wait, dammit.
Where am I?
Oh shit.
Loot, loot, loot.
Okay.
We're so back, dude.
Holy shit.
I think I got it already.
There's no team damage, you stupid.
I need more high value loot.
I bumped into a different team.
Wait, someone died already?
Oh shit.
Multiple people died already.
Have you guys found like a place to...
Oh, like the portals?
No, we haven't.
Kill, kill, kill.
Oh no, we can't kill.
Fuck.
I was so excited, man.
I was so excited.
I don't even know if I have enough stuff.
That's fucked up.
Do you need like help?
Can you talk to someone?
Nah, man, I just need to like cope some way or another, you know?
I got it.
Guys, how the fuck?
Oh, so many chicken!
Oh, chain mail, nice.
Okay.
Oh, people are dying.
Guys, there's so many power.
They're all dying.
Help me, I don't know how to get this.
Wait, how much?
Five minutes, okay.
Yeah, guys, if nobody dies, we're fucking good already.
You can revive people, that's the thing.
You can revive.
But don't they lose all their shit?
No, they don't, unless you revive.
Oh, you just revive?
Okay.
You can steal their stuff.
If you see somebody dead, you can steal their stuff.
Because that's what Wolfie and I did last time.
We're in a really bad area where it's like...
Is it collapsing, actually?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you guys gotta get out.
Oh, fuck.
I'm trying to figure out how to get out.
Yeah, fuck that, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Wolfie, I'm gonna follow you.
There's no fall damage, right?
If I fall down?
Yeah, you can fall down.
Will I live?
Okay, I'm following you because you know where the exit is.
Holy shit!
Fun fact, I don't, but we'll be fine.
Oh, zombie, zombie, careful!
Oh, is the whole team here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's over here, follow the leader!
Hello, gamers.
I'm...
I have a lot of stuff, I need to get rid of stuff.
Hello, my fellow younglings.
If I get rid of my leather...
Oh, I killed him, killed him!
If I get rid of my leather, is that okay?
I'm so good, I'm gonna kill people!
Yeah, you can drop the leather, yeah.
Doki, doki, doki, doki, here, here.
Oh, I have, okay, okay, wait, I'm getting rid of my leather.
Oh, you have pants already?
Yeah, yeah, I have pants.
Wait, I have chain mail.
Oh, there's a whole team down here.
Hold on.
Okay.
We need to be careful, because I don't think this is like...
This might be a little scary.
Can we kill people now?
I'm gonna die.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Wait, wait, are you down there?
Should we go down there with you?
I also have thoughts like that, don't worry, I understand.
I'm gonna come back up.
Okay.
Red team's already been down here, but I'm just grabbing a couple things they missed.
Wait, Michi's dead again?
Dead team, am I right, guys?
So true.
Yeah, yeah, you tell him, bro.
You fucking tell him, bro.
Yeah!
Let's continue forward, gang.
We got it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, god, oh, god, oh, god.
Why is everything crumbling?
There's chain mail stuff here.
Pull and weave, pull and weave, pull and weave.
Nice!
Oh, we have to get out of here, because our entire area is collapsing.
Oh, god.
Die, die, die.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Heck yeah.
Oh, unlooted area, nice.
Bro, this is such a cool game mode.
I like this a lot.
What the fuck?
Go away wither skeleton, man.
Looting.
This is like itching my loot goblin, you know, like mine.
Do you have iron sword?
Oh, I do.
Oh, god.
We're good.
Wait, I see a button.
Oh, hello.
Jesus Christ.
People are just escaping.
Sorry, we can kill people yet.
We're leaving early.
People are leaving already, but there's so much shit to loot.
There's two minutes left.
We have to find a portal.
Wait, I'm in a PvP trunk, I think.
Does it tell you that you can PvP?
Yeah, yeah, get out of there.
You're probably in a PvP trunk, yes.
There's a boss, there's a boss.
Oh, god.
There's a boss in the...
Follow me, follow me.
I have dodgers here.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
My bad.
Over here, over here, over here.
How long until it collapses?
I don't know, but just...
It's orangey?
Yeah, but Feinberg...
Feinberg fucking always fights the boss.
Yeah.
True.
We're better off, like, sporting solid points than going for, like, super risky things.
We have a minute left.
We have to find one now, or we don't bank anything.
Oh, shit, the game's only one...
One minute left!
Stop looting!
We gotta find the portal!
Yeah, there's a portal in this trunk.
We need to find purple candles.
Guys, look for purple candles!
Don't go that way.
Go back, go back.
Wait, wait!
Oh my god, I couldn't...
Wait, I can't... Oh my god, okay.
Let's find the portal.
Yeah, we have 55 seconds.
Stop looting!
We gotta find portal!
Olive?
Oh boy.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, I'm freaking out.
I'm actually freaking out.
Where the hell is the portal?
Hold on.
Why didn't we find portal earlier?
Is it not shown in the map?
No, we have to follow candles.
We're in a portal chunk.
We just need to find it.
I'm gonna go up here.
I'm expecting it to be up somewhere.
Oh, all the fucking sides are like crumbling.
30 seconds.
Come on, Wolfie!
You're the leader!
It's okay, we don't need points anyway.
We don't need points.
Why is purple candle spotted?
Goodbye.
Goodbye, cruel world.
We didn't need points.
You know what?
I blame Wolfie.
I blame Wolfie for that.
Wow.
Dude, it was literally behind us.
That's crazy.
That's insane.
Wait, where?
I didn't think about that.
I think they might have reduced the game time.
Oh, there's a portal.
Wait, what do you mean you think?
You're part of the portal team!
What do you mean you think?
I don't make everything, I promise.
I don't make everything.
Zero...
How do we get 23 points?
I went to a merchant.
And I sold two stone swords.
Oh...
Of course, fine.
Don't worry, guys.
Hey, guys.
Oh my god, guys.
I might need a substitute after that first game, guys.
I don't think...
I'm going to erase my existence from this team.
Winner POV, okay?
Yeah, winner POV, dude.
Look at all these fucking streamers, man.
Guys, guys, please.
Guys, I want to fight.
I want to fight a portal.
Guys, please.
And everybody's like...
Simple, fumble.
We will come back another game.
That kind of sucks because that is literally the game we could have won with our current skill set.
You're so inspirational.
That was an inspirational speech, thank you.
Thank you, appreciate it.
I thought I was a loose goblin.
Bring up Mimi and bring up Nine.
If I leave now, I keep my 100% win rate.
No, no, no.
We are bottom 10, but that's okay.
Wait, what are you guys' score individually?
Check, check.
Where do I see that?
35, fuck!
Wait, what?
I'm 31st.
23.
Look at me, look at me.
You know what I'm surprised?
That phantom's not boost.
What's the next one?
This is the first game, guys.
I didn't see a portal the entire game.
The portal shows up at the last two minutes.
33.
The last two minutes, that's when the portal showed up.
Because it says on the screen, like, oh, portals are opening now.
And it was like two minutes left.
I'm going to be so honest.
I kind of forgot.
Oh shit, let's go.
I will take the blame.
This was my responsibility.
I forgot, I was a big attention.
It's okay, boss, don't worry about it.
What do you mean?
Okay, okay.
I like that one.
The moment in the team when you have to be the responsible one.
And I was like, team, guys, team.
We got five portals, guys.
I'm sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
That's really good.
That moment, you know, what I have to do to see it.
I have to be the straight man.
Bro, the knockback, holy shit.
You know, some things were wrong.
Can we order off?
Yeah, we're coming.
Dude,
this is so much fun.
Wait, wait, wait, who's going to be cooking?
Probably me.
Wolfie.
Yeah, Wolfie.
Don't we need two people cooking?
We need two.
We're going to hit them.
Who wants to be the delivery person?
Yeah, that was me last turn.
I think we should all gather in the start, no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ohio!
I can get the fish in the...
I'll get the fish and meat.
I can do whatever the fuck you want me to do.
I don't know what the hell this is.
I'll go meat first.
I feel like you'd look good in a chef's outfit.
I'll go meat first and then somebody else go fish.
Yeah, I'll be chef.
Okay, so...
Demi, Doki, gather shit.
Wolfie, Hakka, cook.
I deliver.
Okay.
Alright, yeah.
Are we in Ohio?
I feel like Hakka should deliver, no?
We're in Ohio?
I've never been to Ohio.
Okay, Americans, tell me...
If you can, tell me positive things about Ohio.
Or not.
Whoever wants to be the second chef...
with me...
will be the delivery person as well.
There's an Elytra thing...
that could be very useful for delivery.
Because the delivery area is like...
a raised platform...
and you can fly down to the delivery thingy.
You know what?
I can be second chef.
I've done this before.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think Lion should be second chef.
You're stuck to gathering wheat.
You fucking peasant!
Okay, so Lion, you select the Elytra...
by clicking the second inventory slot.
Not again!
Then for gathering...
Why is there a goal on the floor?
There's no mushroom on the floor too.
So I don't think that was supposed to...
I'll go right side.
Somebody go left side and somebody go front.
Yeah, I'll get the wheat and the fish.
I'll get the wheat.
Wheat is in the back.
I'll go in the back too.
Just gather stuff.
Gather stuff first...
and then we'll figure it out.
I have no clue.
Oh, we're so ready.
Maybe it's now collecting gold from the floor.
So the wheat is over there.
Below the big wheat is the wheat.
Oh, there we go.
I'm locked in.
I'm doing all the Minecraft pro stuff.
I jump and swing.
We're in one of the...
I'm locked in.
I'm getting fish now.
I'm gonna get a couple of apples.
Oh yeah, we got lemons.
When life gives you lemons.
Alright, fish time.
I'm gonna put some stuff in the chest now.
Wait, people are already fishing.
I guess I'll do more meat.
Dude, this music is banger.
Who did this?
I'm doing meta.
I learned.
I learned from the first tournament.
It only takes me one game.
It only takes me one game to figure this out.
Does anyone have pumpkins?
I can go get pumpkins.
We have a carrot.
There's carrots right in there.
I got all the vegetables.
Potato, wheat, and carrots.
I'm grabbing apples now.
I'm grabbing pumpkins.
Yeah, I'm currently not in the kitchen.
I'm grabbing pumpkins right now.
We need to...
Rush order will expire soon.
Yeah, we need to rush order stuff.
I'm getting the pumpkin related stuff.
Eggs?
Oh, fuck.
There's eggs already in the chest.
There's already eggs in the chest.
I'm on my way.
I have lemons.
I'm giving you apples, oranges, and lemons.
Is there anything we need right now?
I can get them.
Eggs.
Okay, eggs.
Once you order ready, you can deliver it.
Rush order will expire in 15 seconds.
I'm gonna take this stuff out.
I don't think we're gonna finish it in time.
Where do I drop shit?
Here?
In the chest.
Where the fuck is my customer?
There should be a compass in the middle of your food.
Hurry up, deliver boy!
Yeah, it's like saying 56 meters away from customer.
Do we kill the cows?
It should have an arrow and everything.
Wait, maybe we should swap.
I'm still gonna farm.
Is there anything specific we need?
We need pumpkin.
I got pumpkin.
Where do we get chocolate?
It's in one of the chests.
Hold up, I'll figure it out.
Do I get more wheat?
We don't have enough space for wheat anyway.
I'm gonna put the egg in the floor.
The chest is full.
I'm gonna upgrade the chest.
And then I will upgrade our looting.
What the fuck do you mean I'm a natural environment, you motherfuckers?
We need pumpkin pie and golden carrot.
We have a lot of ingredients for pumpkin and carrots already.
Somebody can get a hoe.
Thank you.
Get a hoe upgrade.
If you're dedicated to getting ingredients.
Right click this thing and click the hoe.
Put it in.
My inventory is full now.
Potato, potato, carrot.
Delivery.
I'll just deliver it.
I'll do a mushroom stew.
I'll get more meat.
Guys, I'm stupid.
Do you have a delivery?
I'm working on one.
There's one ready.
I'll just keep cooking.
I got the other one.
Damn, I'm locked the fuck in.
You guys are right.
Fucking natural habitat.
There's only six teams?
It's not the number of orders.
It's how
the points of the orders.
I'll take care of most of the crafting.
Thank you.
Gathering.
I think we need more stoves.
We need to buy more upgrades.
The thing is not open.
There's no bosses in this anymore.
Feels like home.
We need somebody to cook chicken.
You guys need more meat?
We need mushroom stew.
We do not have a lot of mushrooms.
More wheat and stuff?
How many do you need?
One?
What do I get?
Ready for delivery, I think.
I'll make a couple more.
I'm just going to keep providing.
I'm just going to help with cooking and stuff.
I am literally getting carrots, potatoes, and wheat.
Order ready.
Ready for delivery.
I'm working on one right now.
We need cooked mutton.
Is there cooked mutton?
Let's get some more.
Guys, we need mutton.
Dude, I love this freaking BGM.
I have more fish and meat.
Pumpkin pie.
Lemons.
Another order ready.
Grab more resources.
Yeah, my natural habits as a farmer.
Do you guys need sugar?
Sure.
Okay, I'll grab sugar.
If you have an abundance of one resource, wheat, just decompose it.
Okay, order ready.
Order ready.
I'll take the rush.
Okay, I got vegetables.
I have sugar.
I'll grab more mushrooms.
Wait, what's the gold nuggets for?
You can just drop it on the floor.
We have infinite of that.
Alright, I'm getting more vegetables.
I'll focus on the meat and fish.
You can just focus on veggies, Hakka.
Ready to deliver.
I think we're good on sugar.
We need more meat probably, just in general.
Fish.
Should I help Doki?
Order ready.
Alright, let me just drop this and I'll help you, Doki.
Guys, order up.
Do we need fruit?
We need cookies.
Get fruit.
Go back to the trees.
It's the trees and the sugar canes.
I'll get fruit and you get the meat.
Are you making cookies?
Delivery ready.
We're working on one right now.
Is there a new one ready?
Oh, this one's just oranges and apples.
I've got the lemons.
Can you get the oranges?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, you want to get lemons?
We can have someone else maybe...
Sorry, what did you say?
You want lemons?
No, we're good.
Just getting a couple.
I'll grab more meat.
This is a very fast-paced game, so I'm just spamming.
Let's go.
I'm delivering this thing.
Oh, it's right there.
Just deliver!
Just keep delivering!
You got potatoes?
This shit's raw!
Eat it!
Eat it up!
Oh, that's in the chest.
Right order is ready now.
Two minutes left.
I put meat in there.
What else do we need?
Cooked salmon.
We need cooked salmon.
Oh wait, I need to put on my sugar.
How the fuck do I get fish?
We have salmon in there, didn't we?
Or do we need more?
We have rolling carrots now.
Yeah, we have a lot of salmon.
We're doing pretty good, guys.
Let's go.
Nice!
Okay, I got rush order pretty much done.
Just a little bit more.
I think there's one order that's not being delivered.
And if another one is done soon, then I'm going to...
We have one minute left, so...
We have one minute left, so she gets some deliveries in.
Rush order is ready for delivery.
Give me a second.
I'm done with this one now.
Okay, okay.
Rush order.
I'll go get sugar.
Okay, okay, okay.
We need pumpkins, Haku.
If you're still getting some.
I can get it, I can get it, I can get it.
Okay.
I fell in the water!
40 seconds.
How many pumpkins?
I'm going to get five for now so you guys can make stuff from it.
I put more vegetables and shit there.
Meat, right?
30 seconds.
We need help just crafting things right now.
Alright.
Cod, cod, cod.
I don't have space for it.
Found him, found him, found him.
There's pumpkins in there.
Cod in here.
Order two is ready.
Order two, 10.
Pumpkin pie?
Just focus on the right.
Do we have a baked potato?
Yeah, yeah, we do.
Put it in the right thing.
The right order.
We did good, we did good.
Pretty solid.
Jesus!
Now that's very stressful, I know.
That's a lot going on.
Wait, can we still deliver?
Yeah, you can, you can.
Do we still have any delivery stuff?
No.
Okay, we're good.
The other got 21.
It also depends on the order itself.
We got four.
We'll take that.
That's very good.
Very nice.
50%.
We locked the fuck in.
Feinberg team still got first, that's crazy.
Fourth place, let's go!
How is it crazy?
It's Feinberg.
Let's go!
It is Feinberg, that's true.
That's crazy.
If you have Feinberg on your team, you remove one player.
That's all I'm saying.
He's literally two players.
Kind of unfair.
Or he plays with one arm.
That's all good.
Things are very close right now because of the first game having zero points for half the lobby.
Did they nerf the spawn rate of the portal or something?
No, I think we just generally moved a little slower.
Which is obviously not good.
Really?
That shit feels fast, dude.
We were all grouped up together too because we didn't want to get lost.
Because last time we were split up trying to find portals.
Exactly.
I was in two of them.
How are we last place?
We should stick together.
We didn't get points for the...
Red team beat us by like...
Demi, lock in bro, what are you doing?
Shut the fuck up, Heavenly!
Shut the fuck up!
We have a lot of room to work with though for points.
Which is good.
I am on... Oh, 17!
Holy shit, that's my placing.
Damn.
Look at Lynex, she's looking so beautiful and juicy.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I love your white stuff.
That's my hair, dumbass.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Blue.
I'm so intubated today.
I'm kind of sad that we don't have fucking like...
Luigi nose, man.
I'm so intubated.
When I don't know a majority of people, I'm just so...
Interaction is hard.
Why are you spitting the cookie?
It's situational.
Wait, why are you spitting the cookie?
I'm really nervous.
This has to be some form of autism.
Hello?
No, you're right.
Because when I form collabs myself, like when I invite people to collabs and stuff, I know most of the people.
So like, I make sure I have people I know.
And so like, when I organize the collabs, the introversion doesn't hit as high.
But like, it hits really hard for me when I don't know the people.
I'm just like, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know how the personalities are like.
Alright, fuck it, bro.
Where are we going?
It seems to be that people are...
Oh, nevermind.
I'm so scared.
Okay, let's go for a tracking.
Yeah, everyone seems to know each other already and I'm just like...
I'll get you.
I'm so sorry, I may or may not have been the one to like, do this.
Some people don't respect the sacred art of shifting here in fucking like...
I'm shifting in front of them, they don't shit a shit.
What is this?
We played this last time.
Oh, this is party games, okay.
Are these exact...
Yes, this is Deathmatch, then there's Splatoon.
It's a camera.
This is Splatoon.
So it's the exact same as the last Block Wars.
Oh, okay, so I don't have to learn.
Guys, I've never watched the Block Wars.
Whoa!
I'm sorry, I stuttered.
Dude, I'm so serious, but I don't understand the game, though.
Not a single competitive bone in that fucking show.
I haven't watched the last Block Wars.
I will explain, don't worry.
This is like Fall Guys.
The name Go Down is how you play the game.
So you can sabotage other people, too, by knocking them off.
Can you get fall damage?
Yes, you have to get all the way to the end.
You can get punched, by the way, so careful of that.
And you don't get points unless you make it to the end.
So you have to get points.
Really?
People can sabotage you, so you have to stay away.
Oh, sorry.
What you do is you fall down, you get points for going all the way to the bottom.
You don't want to die.
You don't get points if you die early.
Even though you went really far.
Yep, yep, yep.
Oh my god, I'm going to die.
Careful.
Also, when you hit somebody off...
The fireworks are people actually dying right now.
Son of a bitch, I died!
Also, if you knock somebody off, you can get points from it.
Boosper fucking killed me!
I was literally so locked in!
Target that guy.
Yeah, target that guy.
Target that fucker, man.
What the fuck?
Highkey, get his ass.
He's Norwegian, I don't like those people.
Ooh, what do you do?
Wait, they're real?
Huh?
I'm Norwegian.
Damn.
He's my people!
And there can only be one of us.
Now when I say that, I get in trouble.
Oh my god, bro!
Oh, it's glass.
I just stabbed myself a little bit there.
Now when I say that, it's a problem, huh?
Yeah.
When people are tryharding, I'm literally just chasing them and fighting them.
Bro, every time I fall, I literally lean into the screen.
It's so fucking funny!
No, I died!
I thought I had enough HP.
I'm like fucking sword out of line and shit.
You get points from knocking people off, too.
I die from being stupid.
Unfortunate.
This pig will carry me!
Oh, yeah, the pig takes a damage from...
Oh, it just fucking died from that.
I thought that was gonna save my ass.
Michi, get the fuck away!
No, bitch!
No!
Oh, fuck!
I'm dying!
Where am I?
I heal, I heal, I heal.
I see where I am.
The game is about to end in 30 seconds, guys.
No!
Do you only get points if you make it to the end?
Yeah, and also you kill people, too.
Wait, why are the checkpoints like that?
The glass.
We made it that far, Hucka?
Bro, whoever fucking punched me, their mom's a hoe.
Why are you like a noob?
I'm a noob, bro.
I'm sorry.
I'm almost at the end, guys!
Please, extend the timer!
Bro, who is punching Boosfer?
Man!
This guy's a hater.
Yeah, we're gonna kill Boosfer, man.
His teammates might be talking shit.
You never know, man.
Yeah, bro, what the fuck, man?
Alright, I did small.
That was that.
Hey, we got third in this round.
Oh, hell yeah.
I killed so many people.
I'm focused, bro.
You might be number one in kills.
Kills are worth, like, one point.
Oh, shit.
Wait, kills are worth one point?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was trying to say you out, but I was muted.
I was also muted.
I fucked up.
Yeah, yeah, I was killing people, too.
I was chasing people.
The kills are worth, like, one point.
So, it's not a big deal.
Goddamn.
You guys know Payday?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, Payday.
This is Payday.
We are robbing a bank.
There are gonna be wars.
Wolfie, can I rob your heart?
I can't stop muting myself.
I'm so locked in.
It's cause, like, when a lot of people are talking, I feel bad talking.
Cause then it's like...
I feel like I'm...
I'm, like, adding more noise.
So I'm just trying to, like, interject when I can.
The higher you go in the map, the more, like, high-value loot there is.
And the more loot you're carrying, the slower you become.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you die, you lose half of your loot.
Dude, I'm, like, jamming to this fucking music.
This shit's so good.
It's so good.
Just calm with this shit.
Oh, fuck.
I can't fucking jump.
Fuck this shit.
Oh, no swearing, please.
Yeah, what the fuck?
Uh, yeah, what the...
What the freak?
Yeah, yeah.
I've got lots of loot.
I'm gonna bank it now.
Oh, yeah.
Don't really play too risky, by the way.
Cause that's what I did last time.
Yeah, and then he lost half of his loot.
There's, like, exits on the walls.
Like, exit signs.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just follow the exit sign.
Locked in.
I got a lot of gold.
And you just go to the truck to deposit.
Thank you.
Just follow the exit signs.
I can't read!
There's no text.
It's just the guy.
It's just symbols.
Wait, do you just touch the truck?
How do you do this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You gotta go inside it.
Oh, I think... Wait, do we just go inside it?
Okay, shit, nice.
Just go inside, and then it'll auto-deposit.
Holy shit!
There's one guy, and I got 20 fucking minions!
What's happening?
You're just gonna block...
My iPhone is, like, blocking my screen.
Oh, okay.
Why do you have your iPhone so, like, high up?
VTuber struggle, bro.
Yeah.
Thank God.
I'm, like, next to a guy, and he's aggroing everybody, so they're all hitting him instead of me.
Oh, I see that right now.
Uh-oh.
Son of a bitch.
I can't.
This FOV is so, like, hard to, like, tell, like, how far you guys are.
Yeah.
Coming back with points.
I have points, too.
That's good, that's good.
That's a lot.
Hey, hey, stay away, scarecrow!
I got 100.
I'm on my way.
I'm heading back now.
I'm on my way, guys.
I'm following the exit.
Okay, cool.
How much time we got?
Uh, 40 seconds.
30 seconds, so you should head to the exit if you can.
If you're deep in the area, head to the exit.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
30 seconds.
I placed more.
Stay away, stay away, stay away.
I'm coming, I'm coming back.
Yeah, you only have, like, 20 seconds to gather stuff, and then you have an extra, like, 15 or 30 to, like, go back.
Oh, fuck, oh, fuck, oh, fuck.
I'm getting so heavy.
The exit's outside.
Thanks, Wolfie.
I'm heading over now.
How many seconds to, uh...
You have to go back now.
Okay, I'm gonna follow the green across the map to go out.
The green, like, path.
There's green, like, signs.
Dude, there's someone with, like, 40 mobs on them.
That's crazy.
Oh, god.
There's so many.
Holy shit.
I'm not gonna make it.
That's it.
10 seconds, 10 seconds!
Run!
Bro, I literally couldn't pick shit up.
It's so crowded.
I have 80 points.
Run!
That's crazy.
We're still doing good, guys.
We're still doing good.
Nothing to worry about.
Damn, look at Dunkey!
Holy shit.
I was farming.
I'm a bit of a thief.
Crazy.
Damn.
Yeah,
I shoplift lately.
Yeah, I shoplift lately.
I got sponsored by Payday, like, this week.
Oh.
Oh, my god.
Okay, Splatoon time.
If you kill people, you get points.
There's kill points.
You want to cover the map to reload.
How do you kill somebody?
You just shoot them.
It's like Splatoon.
To reload your gun, you have to shift on top of your color.
So that would be lime.
And then you become a part of it.
You become a part of the color.
You and the color become one.
Oh, you can actually see the leaderboards now.
Because last time you guys fucking hit that shit.
It's because it was the last game.
Oh, the last game you hide it?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, I thought it was just for...
specifically just that.
Just because we didn't want to show you the points.
Yep.
That's where I killed Vinny.
Oh, hold up.
Boost for alert.
Oh, I'm going to die.
Oh, this guy is an actual Minecraft player.
Noob.
What the fuck?
No, he's an actual Minecraft player.
I was trying to bully non-Minecraft players.
No!
Oh, I killed someone.
Who it is?
RabScarecrow?
More like...
Goodbye.
So, wait.
Do we get points for like territory card?
Yeah, we do.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Okay.
It counts like every like minute or so.
I got killed.
Fuck.
All good.
I keep dying.
I'm so sorry.
It's okay.
It's fun.
Oh, no.
I couldn't.
I got points spawned.
Got covered up.
This is fucked up.
This is so fucked up.
This is crazy.
No!
Trying to cover.
I should actually like target people and not just fucking pains.
I should do both at the same time.
Right.
Die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Oh, get fucked.
Oh, fuck.
I died.
Oh, shit.
Someone spawned behind...
JoeBart.
Fuck you, man.
We are the non-Minecraft players.
Oh, fuck you, Joe.
Oh, fuck you, Joe!
Guys, spill it, spill it!
No, you're a natural Minecraft player!
We have 43 seconds left.
Oh, I killed Shirahiko, okay.
I died again, fuck.
Fuck, okay.
No!
I'm, like, being followed.
Ah, fuck.
Huge.
I'm just trickshotting people.
I think we should cover more.
Yeah, we should focus on covering right now.
Whoever shot me, your mom's a hoe!
Oh, what?
Oh, there's guys behind me!
Fuck.
He got...
Pranked!
Oh, my God.
No!
This is literally Splatoon, yeah.
Alright, we did alright.
I killed five people.
Yay!
Oh, the points are, like, super close.
Okay.
Now it's deathmatch time.
Oh, we have so low points...
Is it because of, like, the first game?
No, no, no, that's just because we probably didn't shoot too much area, which is alright.
It could also be because people, like, cover our area, which is, like, unlucky.
Hold on.
Alright.
This is deathmatch.
Like, Valorant deathmatch.
Or CS, or whatever.
I don't remember this.
Oh, this is...
One shot.
Oh, God.
Oh, I love this one.
Oh, so the spawn's fucking stupid.
You literally spawn camp.
If you spawn that area, they're all gonna spawn that area, too.
Oh!
I found that out.
You right-click, right?
Yeah.
It auto-recharges for you, as well.
Oh, really?
Why don't you, I think, crash?
So, we're waiting.
Oh, okay.
Now, good.
That's a drinking water moment.
It's right-click, right?
Is it right-click?
Oh, guys, we're above, like, red team.
Like, so far ahead from red team.
That's good.
That's the opposition.
Okay.
All we have to do is...
You just spawn camp.
That's the strat.
Yeah.
They all spawn in it.
It's, like, designated spawns every time.
It's not randomized.
Which is what I found out in the last, like, minute.
Okay.
I'm so bad, guys.
Let's go.
My PC blew the screen.
Oh!
You're, like, lagging a little, too.
Yeah.
Uh...
If this happens again, I might...
Might be my 13th reason.
Oh, hell no.
What were the other 12?
I'm kidding!
Like, who was it?
Axis.
Call them out.
Alright, guys.
Start fragging out.
Oh my god, where are they spawning?
It's time to lock in.
Yeah.
There's, like, nobody here.
Where?
Boost for alert.
I'm gonna get shot in the back.
I can feel it.
Oh, come on, man.
As you said that, I got shot in the back.
No!
This is Demi's game.
Lock in.
Bro, there's no reason for you to fucking dodge.
It's all about time.
That's what I'm saying.
You know where the spawns are?
Just fucking stay there.
Holy shit, okay.
But I feel like...
The spawn...
The spawn rate lowered.
It's not as bad as last time.
Oh, it's Demi.
I wanna go back to farming, bro.
Where did you get shot?
No!
Oh my god, where was that?
Dude, Hakka, when you retire, you should open a farm.
Yeah, that's a dream.
No, behind me, of course.
They both start with an F.
True, actually.
Oh, I killed Grimmy.
Oh my god.
I didn't even get shot first.
Fuck you, Heavenly!
I avenged you, Demi.
I did this for you.
Thank you, I appreciate that.
I did this for all the pregnant men in the world.
Okay.
Amen.
There's gotta be a lot of those.
How did I die?
That fucking Elmo guy is crazy.
Hello, guys.
Oh, Heavenly got me again.
Oh god.
So many people here play Valorant.
I'm missing everything, guys!
What the fuck is happening?
Bro, people are sweating.
People are fucking sweating on Minecraft.
This is ridiculous.
Yeah, man.
Okay.
This game mode is super sweaty.
Oh, I saw her too late.
This is like bullying a baby, man.
Oh, he's low, he's low.
Are you the baby?
I was gonna say, he's low.
He's low.
I mean, he's next to me.
Not the Among Us!
I got fucked by the Among Us.
Guys, he's 1 HP.
That's fine, anybody.
Oh, there he is.
This guy is gonna get botted, bro.
No way!
I'm killing myself.
No!
The fucking 360!
Now it's just Minecraft that crashed.
I don't want a 1v1 fight.
Did you crash?
Yeah, my Minecraft crashed though.
Oh, you did it?
No!
That's unlucky.
Wait, your Minecraft crashed again?
Yeah, now it's just Minecraft, not my PC.
Damn.
Is your CPU getting overloaded or something?
I don't think so.
Jesus Christ, 29.
29?!
I was barely firing people for mine.
I killed 6 people.
I did not do good.
I got 12.
12 kills.
People were not spawning.
Yeah, there were so many times where I'm just alone.
Yeah.
I was looking for people and I just got killed in the back.
Why is this meat over here?
It tells you at the bottom left when you are...
Oh, we are in the right side too.
Wait, did your kills not count because you crashed?
No, I think they should.
I'm still in the game.
Yeah.
There we go.
Boom.
So scuffed, man.
Holy shit.
Unfortunate.
Unlucky.
Maybe Boosfer is DDoSing you.
They are DDoSing you, bro.
Not last.
Let's go.
Dude, my enemies.
They fear me.
Guys, we are 8.
Holy shit.
Are we?
We are 8, yeah.
Hold on.
The last one.
Yeah, let's go.
Oh, shit.
I'm 26.
Individually.
We did pretty solid last game, though.
Demi got 18.
At least I'm not...
At least I know it's not me.
Hey, last game.
I'm looking at it right now.
18, Demi, 19, Reinho.
Noob alert.
Did you say Noob alert?
Yeah, Noob alert on Reinho.
Life is not Roblox.
Okay, so...
All we have to do is...
You see the bottom 5 players?
Individually?
We just gotta...
We just gotta bully the...
The last 5 players here.
Yeah, we just gotta...
Except for Hakka, because he's on our team.
That's crazy.
Feinberg is like...
Two of the players are in the bottom 5, but Feinberg is actually single-handedly carrying this entire team.
For first place.
This guy is insane.
I think if we split the team properly...
No, I'm talking to you guys.
That's the Valorant CS 5v5 thingy.
Oh god.
That's crazy though.
It's pretty rough.
I feel like the moment the bomb goes down...
It's not even about the bomb.
No, that's finals.
It's okay, we don't have to think about the finals.
We don't have to think about the finals.
Let's just think about surviving first.
The last time we went to the last place...
And stuff...
There was a huge issue where...
It just never felt like...
It was about the bomb anymore.
It was just about the shooting.
It was because it was very laggy.
Yeah, it was so laggy.
Should we race?
We can try a race.
We can do...
I think race or trailblazers.
What the fuck is this guy?
Trailblazers is like parkour and stuff.
No matter what I pick...
What I want...
Nobody would get what I want.
Take me out of my misery.
TAKE ME OUT OF THIS MISERY!
Yeeeees.
And now I leave.
Look at this target simulator.
Wait, there's a fucking hot air balloon.
Okay, spleef, target...
Boosfer.
That's all that matters.
What is this?
What do we get?
You break the blocks below people's feet.
I escape.
You get 10 extra points if you kill Boosfer.
Wait, what is this?
Spleef, you break the blocks below people's feet.
Oh, the survive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, good luck everyone.
There's two rounds of this and there's a TNT round.
This one is pretty chill.
You just break blocks, you throw snowballs.
Make friends.
They'll fuck you over.
Social game.
And pray.
Just present your behind and they'll be okay.
Yo.
I mean, you femboys know what to do.
Yeah, my nape is exposed right there, bro.
Anyways, guys.
In this economy, that's what you have to do.
I didn't want to ask.
Have you ever seen Attack on Titan?
It's by far your neck.
Yeah, that's where the Titan shifters hide, bro.
What's up?
Bye.
You're gonna get a shovel, pickaxe, one of the two.
Break blocks.
Careful of people.
No, they don't want to be friends!
Second, you bitch!
Oh, motherfucker!
Oh, God.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna run.
Fuck this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Running is lucky.
Oh, you bitch-ass bitch.
I don't have the brain capacity to do two things at once.
No, people are not...
Oh, I think it's because it's rookie.
People aren't doing friendship because they don't know.
Yeah, they're just super angry.
They're so angry and aggressive.
All they do is...
All they do is mind the boss.
Oh, my God, bro!
Okay, I may have access...
I saw that!
Last layer unlocked.
Oopsies, guys.
Fuck you, Shadow.
Why would you do this?
Oh, shit.
Is this the last layer?
Am I fucked?
Oh, I'm so fucked.
Hey, second.
Fuck out of here, bro.
Alright, Pyre Software.
We are gonna be friends!
Bro, fuck me.
Oh, God.
Oh, fucking rain!
Hello, Demi.
Hi!
Dude, I'm actually getting targeted right now.
Yeah, I have a friend!
I have a friend!
Yeah, I have friends!
No, my friend!
Can I kill your friend?
No, I'm at the top layer.
Friend?
This top layer is looking very interesting.
No, Giga, you son of a bitch!
My friend!
Who's friending?
This fucker!
Nice, Demi.
I'm on the top layer by myself.
Shit!
Fuck!
I'm so fucked.
It's fine, bro.
It's over.
I'm dead as fuck.
We're good here.
I made friends with people, so people were super nice to me.
Oh, there's a guy below me.
He doesn't like me.
It might be Zacian.
I might have made him a little bit angry.
Sorry.
I don't trust Feinberg.
Feinberg is not attacking, but he's scaring me to shit.
He really is bleeping, man.
Dude, Feinberg's just pure aura scares me, man.
Yeah, I know, right?
Who did that?
You got killed by a sandwich lord.
No!
I've been for so long at the top, dude!
And I fell all the way to the bottom after living at the top.
How are you kidding me?
I literally fell...
No!
I fell at like...
Oh my god.
Come on, Demi.
No, Demi, no!
You did well, Demi.
I killed him.
You went crazy, dude.
You got third.
I did not get to kill him, but that's all good.
Guys, just do that again.
That was good.
Just make friends.
Make friends, but trade them.
Red team is not our friend, I think.
No, no, no.
Pirate software was super nice.
Wait, but he's not red.
He's not pink.
He was very nice to me.
Oh my god, they started!
I was not ready for this.
These fuckers.
Oh, that's one down.
Oh god!
Please don't do this to me.
I love the sound effect of breaking the blocks.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
I'm so sorry.
Oh god.
Dude, these fuckers are so fast with fucking sleeping, man.
It's crazy.
These motherfuckers need to stop.
Oh, he's after me!
I'm on the third layer, so I'm going to play very carefully.
Yeah, me too.
Oh, you fucking bitch.
Stop!
Whoever did that, fuck you.
Holy shit.
That was insane.
It's the fucking Among Us skin!
Amogus, guys.
Amogus!
Alright, I'm targeting Amici.
This is terrifying.
This is so terrifying when you're at the top.
Because it's like, when you're at the top, it's like everybody wants to kill you, and then you don't know where to go.
You can fall to the very bottom accidentally, and it's terrifying.
Oh, I killed Grimmy!
Oh my god!
Line, we should really stay in this level.
I killed someone else!
You guys got that.
Shiraz!
No!
I fall to the bottom.
I'm like, wait, Sleepy's actually targeting me.
This is crazy, man.
Please leave me alone.
I miss having friends.
Nice one, Obi!
Nice one, nice one!
Oh god, one second.
We've made the mad...
It's like punching a wasp's nest.
The whole team is gravitating...
Having friends was so fun.
I miss it.
No!
Dude!
Fucking Michi, man.
I got three kills, though.
That was pretty good.
We're good, we're good.
Just chill.
Yeah, I'm evading the sensor.
I'm the last level.
That's fine, dude.
Look, you're so getting targeted, dude.
Holy shit.
I miss having friends.
Holy shit, holy shit.
Oh, nice, though!
Holy fuck!
No, I died first!
I got points, though.
I got points for it.
That's good, that's good.
I got two points from kills.
Useless.
I miss the two friends I made in the first game.
Wow, Ashlea is still on top.
Jesus.
Yeah, but he can get very unlucky if he fell straight down.
Oh, true.
Oh, look at Wolfie.
Oh my god!
Can you left click and hit somebody or does it have to be snowball?
Go, Wolfie!
Oh, Wolfie's dead.
You can punch somebody, right?
You can punch, right?
You can punch?
Okay.
Wait, you can or you can't?
You cannot.
Wait a second, guys.
We're doing good.
Okay, this one, you get a bow and arrow.
When you shoot, it's like a 3x3 area.
You also get a crossbow that's automatically charged.
You can, like, jump up with it.
Yeah, you can launch yourself.
You can what?
Jump up and what?
You can launch yourself up.
You can, like, test it at the start.
Yeah, yeah, rocket jump.
We can rocket jump.
I forgot about rocket jumping.
I don't trust myself rocket jumping.
I don't know for, like, just fighting people.
I don't trust myself at all.
Oh, Wolfie!
Sorry!
I thought it was you!
I almost fell all the way down.
Oh, my goodness.
Jesus Christ.
We're good.
Oh, my God.
The whole lobby.
Be angry.
That's crazy, but...
I'll figure it out, though.
It's true.
Oh, yeah.
That's definitely the reason.
Oh, sorry.
I shot you away.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah.
Fuck you, Archibald.
Fuck you!
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
I hate these VTubers.
Yo, same.
Yeah, fuck them VTubers, dude.
No.
You can use your arrows to shoot people, too.
I can't do it.
It's so hard.
It might be a pain thing.
It might be, like, really difficult with pain.
Fuck, it's so hard.
I can't.
You can, like, shoot people with the bow.
Yeah, like, directly.
Oh.
I'm coming for revenge.
Never mind.
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
Okay.
I didn't even land.
Oh, God.
Fuck you, Among Us.
I got the Among Us.
Oh, God, no!
I'm dead.
Fuck.
I got three kills, though.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
Where am I going?
I don't trust myself rocket jumping.
Last time I tried rocket jumping, I actually died.
Yeah.
I believe in you.
Oh, my God, what the hell?
People keep shooting me.
Okay.
Maybe this is my...
Oh, you did it!
I got pre-fired by fucking infected men.
Holy shit.
Damn, Doki.
You look like a porcupine.
Holy shit.
Dude, I got a cook at the...
No, no!
Oh, no.
I think I got one.
No!
I was doing so well, too.
Oh, damn.
Fuck.
I actually figured out how to rocket jump.
We're good.
Don't let Sleepy live.
Don't let him live.
It's you.
It's 1v...
Oh, it's 1v1.
Oh, 1v2.
Oh, Wolfie, watch out.
Yo!
No way!
Oh, my God, he's actually gaming.
No!
He jumped on the only other yellow.
That's actually crazy.
That is insane.
Holy shit.
He jumped on the only other one.
Wait, how many games is it?
We might not get it, guys.
Oh, my God.
Let's go!
The bare minimum!
Eight people.
Yeah, he just went for Vtubers.
Let's go!
Ban all Minecraft players.
Hey, not last.
The bare minimum!
Let's go!
Wait, how is the comments doing so much better now?
Because they got 300 more points than us in this game.
Oh, wow.
The point gap is pretty close across the board.
It's the red debuff, bro.
Just ignore blue team.
How many more games do we have left?
I forgot.
We're halfway?
Yeah, we're halfway through.
We've played like one of the lot...
We've played two of the lot.
I'm almost top 10!
Let's go!
I'm 23rd!
I'm almost top 10!
Let's go!
I'm 14th!
I don't know what I did, but let's fucking go!
I'm 40th!
Let's fucking go!
It's your first tournament.
It's your first one.
This is my second one, but it's okay.
Is it actually last place?
Yeah, 40th is dead last.
No, there's a 41st player.
Don't listen to them.
There's a 41st player.
You're like second last.
Which is better!
It's better because we're second last too.
Yeah, there's a 41st player.
You just can't scroll down to see it.
I know, I know.
Life is good, isn't it?
Slight difference, but that's what we're here for.
I'm like a couple of points behind.
Dude, I'm getting diffed by fucking Zacid.
He hasn't even played before.
That's actually insane.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Is SandwichLord a veteran in the Minecraft?
Yeah, of course, from behind.
SandwichLord is like a very good event player.
Dude, Misty is 7th.
I'm kind of disappointed.
Misty, pick it up, man.
Is he considered the rookie or the pro in this team?
I love Misty.
Sleepy?
No, Misty.
Mistycat.
Misty is the pro.
Misty is kind of goated.
Misty made a circle in Minecraft.
Yeah, yeah.
Because I remember you were saying Misty was a rookie in the last one.
So I was like confused how Misty could be a rookie in the last rookie tournament.
True.
This game is silly.
Yo.
Wow, look at Wolfy be number 6, bro.
Let's fucking go.
Yeah, you know Lightwork.
That's a rep, you know.
It's almost like they organized the event.
They did in fact check me, guys.
So like, let's protect guys because they think I'm 15.
Okay, I've successfully gaslighted them.
I actually don't know.
I've successfully gaslighted them.
That matters.
That's all that matters.
If he's higher than me, I might cry.
I might leave.
12th?
Alright.
Where's the overall?
Hey, Among Uskin.
Among Uskin.
I mean, it's pretty.
That's such a funny just a sentence.
Among Uskin.
Who's Peter Griffin?
I'm pretty sure that's Tom.
Yeah, Tom.
Peter?
Hey, Peter.
Why do you spell it like that?
My God, I've got more than...
In the last game, all I'm saying...
I don't like the bread.
It's pretty good.
All I'm saying, this is where I'm at.
We went crazy last game.
This is where some of the Minecraft pros are at.
That's not me.
My bad, guys.
That's all that matters.
Imagine a grandpa in thigh-highs and skirt.
I was surprised how well I did during Spleef.
I thought Spleef is more about parkour.
I was very surprised while I was doing it.
I was actually...
Are you guys proud of me?
I was rocket jumping.
If I didn't fuck up with...
The first Spleef round, I fucking fell straight down.
That's because I fell straight down.
I could have lived for so long.
I'm going to get some water.
Yeah, me too, actually.
I'm doing it, guys.
I'm getting better.
Hardcore Minecraft trained me for this.
It did.
It trained me so well.
I think it's because I understand the game now, too.
Because when I first loaded in to the block wars, I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
I didn't know what the games are, but now I know.
Shooting all those gas prepared me for this.
I could actually aim because of all the fucking gas I had to fight during that 14-hour run.
14-hour run.
I figured out how to shoot.
I think that also helped me a lot with shooting the bow.
The amount of gas I had to fucking kill.
I tried to convince Min to play block wars, but she was really anxious about a tournament setting.
She was like, oh my gosh, it's a tournament.
I don't know.
Maybe next time.
No, I don't want peer pressure here.
Because I was like, oh, it's rookies.
It's a beginner place.
I am moisturized.
Hydrated even.
Yeah, I was trying to convince her to be on my team for this block wars.
Because they were telling me it was all beginners.
I was like, oh my god, that's good.
She was really anxious about a tournament setting.
It's still competitive.
Even if it's laid back.
I was getting super competitive in the first game because I was just like, guys!
Guys!
Portal!
Portal, guys!
After the first game, I swapped my mindset because it's more casual and stuff.
I'm just playing the game.
It's definitely very...
Even if it's more laid back, it's still competitive.
I was just like, what the fuck?
She was like, oh.
This guy was like, I'm going to put a honey pot in my fruit punch.
I'm locked in today.
Are you drugging people?
What's happening?
What the fuck is happening, bro?
Guys are going to be bricked up walking in the mall.
Yeah, yeah.
Lowkey though, I feel like spiking your friends because the first tournament, I was so locked in.
Not locked in, but people were so fucking competitive in the first Black Wars I did.
My heart was beating hard, but this one, I'm more relaxed.
I think that's why I perform better when I'm super relaxed as well.
What is this conversation?
Yeah.
You're second to the last.
What's going on?
That is why he's second to last.
That's the reason why.
What the fuck, man?
It's November, guys.
It's NNN.
God, I'm here for a fun time, not a long time.
Goddamn.
No, no, no.
It's just November.
You shouldn't be having fun right now.
Listen, it's fucking lying talking about the fucking honey pack and shit, bro.
Feeding by Yagra takes fucking friends and shit, too.
Norwegians go hard.
Imagine, though.
You have the local fruit punch in the sink.
You know, the big-ass fruit punch.
Everyone just gets very confused.
That's very funny.
Everyone gets confused.
Everyone's like, I didn't check in on time.
I'm a worker, bro.
As long as we're not I'm happy.
I can go to dance lessons happy.
And then also be a bit sad because I'm going to dance lessons.
It's the goal.
Crazy.
It's not fun to be undefeated.
It sucks that we were straight away defeated.
I mean, that sucks.
I mean, it's unfortunate that it's like right away we lose 100%.
Who's taking a shit, bro?
What?
Pirate Software forgot to ready up last one.
Mm-hmm.
The people of Toronto want to shop.
Yeah.
Some people in this lobby has not even won a single one yet.
So like...
I always wonder, people that go into game tournaments what do you think when you fucking have to pee and you're in the middle of...
Well, you go to the bathroom before it happens.
Yes, but it still can happen.
Well, if you're dead, then you have a break.
And usually in competitive games, you can call for timeouts and stuff.
Oh.
But there's a limit.
Each team has one to two timeouts that they can call.
Okay.
I can just imagine Faker being like, fuck, I gotta piss.
You know?
I can just imagine that shit.
Everything is balanced.
It's like high-stake competitive gaming, bro.
Who are you?
I thought we were raiding.
We already readied up.
Somebody not readied?
Red and pink.
Or Thor, I think.
I think we should ban every person that looks like that.
Sleepy.
Classic.
Remove them from the lobby!
And then what?
And then we just keep going!
Then we win!
If we're too soft on them, they will keep...
They will think there's no punishment.
That's two players left.
That will make me on 38th place.
That's fucking epic, bro.
Where are you from?
Sina Kuni.
Dox yourself now.
Dox yourself now in front of everybody.
Might as well just write it in chat.
Wait, is that actually not allowed?
I don't think so, no.
No, no, it's not.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know about that.
It's okay.
It's just rules.
I have a wonder to side-see.
I'm so fucking sorry.
I don't really know about that area.
I speak Spanish.
That's all I can say.
It's the difference between YouTube VTubers and Twitch VTubers.
I'm so sorry.
You were just curious.
We have the same accent exactly with my friends.
I'm so sorry to hear that.
Why'd you say it like that?
I'm so sorry to hear that, man.
Whoever your friend is, I wish them luck.
Haka is from Orange County Jail.
Yeah, bro.
I'm Californian.
Can't you just tell?
Well, there's Californians in...
Wait.
That's not part of your lore.
You're ruining the immersion, Haka.
You're ruining it.
Holy shit.
I never knew that you guys are not allowed to say that.
My bad.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Alright, guys.
This is race.
I love race.
Wait, is this the same one?
This is a different map?
I love this map.
This is the only map I did this late at.
Why does this look harder than the fucking first map we did?
What the fuck is this?
All I'm saying is that this is definitely not rookie friendly with all this parkour.
Oh, no, it is.
Yeah, no, it is.
I felt like that first one I did seemed more friendly.
No, the first one we did last time has, like, things where you have to use, like, tridents and stuff.
And that's kind of hard.
No, that was cool.
I like tridents, bro.
It is cool.
It's optional.
I just see so many parkour.
Just go to the hard path.
It's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
Wait, where's the starting line?
It's like a...
No, I'm going to go hard.
I'm going to go hard.
Let's go.
What's the worst that could happen?
I mean, if you just miss a jump, you just go down.
Yeah, exactly.
Just go down and join the Weenie Hut juniors.
I was ninth.
Highlight of my career.
For one second, I was ninth.
Holy highlight.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, shit.
Guys, lock in.
Wait, what?
Oh, you have to jump on those pads.
I didn't realize.
Easy path it is.
Oh my god.
I got confused.
He jumped so far.
No, the boat is where...
I'm locked in.
I'm so fucked, guys.
I'm so fucked.
Just go forward.
Just keep going.
Let's go.
Fuck this shit, bro.
Oh, boat.
Okay, fuck.
You're only going to the boat now?
Let's go.
40th place, baby.
I'm swerving.
Guys, I'm so fucked.
Guys, hook up on the sprint button.
Let's go.
I'm swerving.
Dude, I just did a...
Fucking... I just did a...
Generational fuck up.
I got confused.
I hit my head.
Oh, god.
I don't even know what you're laughing at.
Wait, what?
You can...
I'm so fucked.
I didn't realize.
Yay!
If anyone has anything that's not clear, I will try my best.
Oh, I see sandwich.
Can you make it clear for me?
Let me be clear.
I'm so glad you understood that.
Because so many people wouldn't.
That's because of the hard map, bro.
Fuck this shit.
We're going hard.
Oh, my god.
That was a fucking block.
I feel like a bird sometimes looking at this.
Shit.
Oh, I see a hard path.
Oh, my god.
I'm fucking...
I have like...
Three brain cells left in my head.
Oh, I see a thing up here.
Oh, that's so unlucky.
That's actually so fucking unlucky.
Dude, some people are walking back...
and it makes me feel like I'm literally going the wrong way.
I feel so stupid.
I did first place finish.
Oh, that's huge.
Wait, how many laps is this?
This will tell me if I'm going the wrong way, right?
It won't tell you if you're going the wrong way.
But you can tell, right?
There's arrows around the map that'll tell you what to do.
I'm Weenie Hut Jr-ing.
Yeah, you feel it, right?
Fuck that.
I was like, I messed up one of them...
and it respawns you to the other end.
And I'm like, it's Weenie Hut time.
There we go, there we go.
Okay, now I'm locked in.
I'm so confused sometimes.
Oh, shit.
I thought that was the path.
Goddamn.
Why did it jump me?
What?
Oh, God.
I'm hitting my head.
Easy path, bro.
Fuck this shit.
Nah, some of them are actually so hard.
Nevermind, no, you're right.
This is easier than the last map we did.
Yeah.
First place might be gone, but that's okay.
I'm at number three with the kids.
It's all good.
Sandwich Lord and Feinberg.
Of course, man!
What else would it be?
Do it, do it!
Wait, Wolfie, were you in San Diego?
No.
I'm EU, it's pretty far away, man.
I know, I was there, though.
Oh, oops.
Yeah, lap one finished, baby, let's go!
Lap two!
Hakka, just saying, you need to complete it, because they can actually kick you out if you don't complete it.
Oh no, you're going to complete it, it's fine.
I'm doing so well, bro.
Crazy, crazy, crazy.
I believe, Hakka, I believe.
I'm so good, I'm so good, insane.
I'm so glad you're here.
Bro, thank you, I appreciate that.
You made me feel so much better about myself.
Yeah, yeah, I'm happy to hear that.
That's actually crazy.
That's mental.
Crazy.
I mean, when they really said Neo in the fucking promo image, they really meant it, you know?
Like, just saying, like...
Not just new to Block, or just new to Minecraft, honestly.
Yeah, bro, just new to fucking life in general.
Let's go!
I'm a weenie hut junior!
Fucking weenie hutting!
It's okay, bro, see, this is why I'm a Variety streamer, exactly.
Yeah.
Fuck them gaming shit, bro.
We can suck together.
Yeah, exactly.
Whoa.
Noor!
How do you activate the pink, by the way?
How do you activate...
How do you activate the pink stuff?
You just walk over it.
Oh, that's it?
Okay.
It's like the Sonic dash thingy.
Oh my fuck, that scared the shit out of me.
Bumble alert.
This one I won't cumble so hard again.
I've had like multiple generations.
Wait, what?
Why did it jump?
What the fuck?
I need Feinberg to fail a jump right now, preying on his downfall.
I need Feinberg to crash, please.
Oh my god.
Just kill them.
He failed a jump!
Wait, there's hope!
Huge!
Please!
Get first, Wolfie!
It's gonna be third, but...
Oh, that's still good.
That's almost like first.
That's still really good.
Oh, fuck!
Let's go!
Okay, I'll help you guys.
Okay, go to Haka.
Oh, shit.
Why did you make me go to Haka?
I was doing my fucking best!
He's here to help you!
That's what you meant!
Do you not want to help?
No!
Where's Haka?
Okay, Haka, you got it.
Go onto the stone.
Yep, perfect.
And then just go for the green path.
Then you jump over and go right again.
Fine!
Yeah, just go right.
And then just go for the green again.
Yep, perfect.
Thanks, Wolfie.
You're welcome.
He didn't want that help earlier!
Was that not a good idea?
I don't need the fucking help!
I've done this!
This is my second lap!
Okay, now you're going to do it better.
It's an optimization.
True, true, true.
You're optimizing it.
Who else is close?
Let me see.
True, true, true.
I see Lionchu.
I see Doki.
I see Tom.
Weenie Hut Jr. I see Demma as well.
Weenie Hut Jr. Let's go, squad!
We're so ready, bro.
36, man.
At least not 48.
That's insane to me.
Okay, Weenie Hut Jr. time.
Weenie Hut Jr. I mean, fuck you all!
Fuck this boat, man.
Fuck this boat.
What is happening?
That's insane.
I finished one fucking spot in front of me.
I went to Weenie Hut.
I got Weenie Hut Jr'd hard.
No, you're good.
Solid 21st.
That's good.
Yay!
I'm just scared to go the hard path with parkour.
You're good, Demma.
You're going to get like 25th.
That's perfect.
Love to see it.
I got fucked over at the very end and lost my 20th place.
We need these consistent placements.
We're doing good at this game.
We take this.
I think it's actually the best I've ever done in a race.
Yay!
Good job.
Fuck!
Yay!
You got this!
Wait, is she like ahead?
Or like a lap?
Who, Mega?
Yeah, or is she saved?
No, this is the same lap.
Okay, Haka, you got this.
Come on, go Haka!
We're watching you.
No pressure.
No pressure, we're watching you.
I'm watching you.
Yeah, we're all watching you.
All four of us are locked into you right now.
Yeah, you're going to go in front of her!
You got it.
Yes!
Yes, you can do this.
Just remember...
If you're ahead of her...
Keep sprint jumping.
Never stop, never stop.
You're going, you're going.
You're so ahead of her, but don't look back.
Don't look behind you.
You got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Go, go, go!
Beautiful.
Go!
Do all of that.
She's a weenie hut junior.
Beautiful.
Nice!
To the right!
Okay, same thing.
When you jump over, go to the right.
Yup, yup, yup.
Jump, jump, jump!
Jump running!
Someone fell.
Ignore them!
Who cares?
Oh my god, Peter!
Peter Griffin!
Okay, you got room to catch up maybe.
You gotta hook it, just jump!
You're ahead of two people!
Go at the bottom, go at the bottom!
Just keep going!
My stamina!
Nice!
Yay!
You're not last, you're not last!
I'm not last!
You did it!
Let's go!
Look at that!
What a fucking turnaround!
We gained a bunch of points here over Purple Team.
This is big.
That's fucking good!
Thanks, I appreciate it.
That makes me happy.
We did it guys, we did it.
We're so good, we're so good.
I beat Peter Griffin and to me that's a fucking win.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a win.
You're gonna be the new Peter now.
Oh god, what am I watching?
Oh god.
Wait, is there more people?
Yeah, there's two more.
Wait, what?
Oh wait, you were on the previous lap?
Yeah, actually there's four left.
There's four left.
You're amazing.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
This is interesting gameplay.
Wait, so Peter was like a map behind you?
Yeah, he was a map behind me.
Holy shit.
Okay, hold on.
What place is Groovy, huh?
Uh...
Um...
No, Groovy!
Oh, Parky just finished?
Huge.
Okay, have we got GrubChad?
I don't know.
I think GrubChad just subbed in.
Okay, perfect.
They're doing great.
Oh, that's the easy path.
Come on, Peter.
All cheering for Peter Griffin.
Peter.
Hey, lowers.
Let's go, top.
I don't know how they did that, but perfect.
They're doing great.
Wait, Peter's last?
Peter's last now.
Wait, is Peter last or is Groovy last?
No, Groovy's last.
No, Groovy's ahead.
Groovy's ahead.
Never mind.
No, Groovy's ahead.
That's what I'm saying.
I was looking at Groovy being ahead.
Holy shit.
Hold on, let's go.
Perfect.
God damn.
What did Peter do?
What was he doing?
Let's go, Groovy.
Peter's about to exit the water.
Come on, Groovy.
Let them finish the race.
I'm doing it with you, Groovy.
Come on, Groovy.
How did I do this last time?
Insane.
Come on, Groovy.
Jump, Groovy.
No, Groovy.
Fuck yeah.
Huge.
Wait, where's Peter?
Peter's right behind her.
Peter fucked up the slide.
I knew doing parkour challenged.
I got 25th place.
I think we had 19th, 21st, and 25th.
I got 17th.
Oh, I got 24th.
That's the highest I've ever gotten.
I don't understand this time.
How do you do this one?
Bob, just move closer.
Just move closer, please.
Oh, it's like that.
Nice, nice.
Come on, Peter.
Just do weenie hut.
Somehow, this makes me feel better about myself.
I don't understand how to do the hard part of this one.
It's like harder jumps and then the launch pad goes to the extended...
Come on, Groovy.
Go, Groovy.
I believe in you, Groovy.
10 seconds, Groovy.
No, Groovy.
They're just hard jumps.
Is Bob gonna finish?
So close.
Do you get points if you finish?
Or if you don't finish?
You still get points for the laps, so Groovy will get some points.
Peter did it.
I can't believe I got 17th.
I've never gotten that high.
Okay, let's go.
Breakdown time.
My goat.
This will be big.
Peter Griffin and my goat.
Let's go.
36 plays, baby.
Let's go, baby.
Huge.
Feinberg noob.
Beaten by not even half a second.
Fastest lap.
Oh my god, sleepy.
Yeah, I saw that.
Is this the biggest lap improvement?
Sixth placement.
Huge.
A light second.
We take it.
Oh, he went up as well.
Sixth place.
Let's go.
Now there's multipliers.
How many games left now?
We can get third.
Really hard.
We can get third place.
Not even the finals.
Third place.
You still have to watch.
Nobody remembers third.
It was me.
I'm so close.
My first proper block course, I got 40th.
It's just off from here.
It's going to go crazy.
You literally can't do worse.
You're good.
You can catch up technically.
You can.
Yeah?
I think you can catch up.
It's possible.
I believe so hard.
Thank you.
You guys honor me.
You guys make me feel better.
If you win, I'll give you...
One of them believes in me.
One of them almost made me dox myself.
If you get 35th place, I'll give you 10 subs.
I'll give you one sub.
This is a dream.
If you get above 40th, I'll give you one sub.
We'll all give you one sub.
All is in those two.
I'll give you a sub for each.
Don't use the cheaper deck.
Because...
I was going to say...
A sub is like subscribing to a channel.
In YouTube.
You did catch that.
I was like...
My bad.
Once you move up, I'll give you a sub.
I'll make a new account and subscribe to you.
He's just going to subscribe to you.
I'll give you a sub.
I'll give you a subscriber.
I'll give you a membership.
Thank you.
Don't keep her subscribed to my channel.
Insane.
Don't worry.
I didn't.
LOL But if you're not last place...
I will subscribe to your channel.
If you get out of 40th place...
I'll subscribe to your channel.
Wow.
Trailblazers is what we vote for.
Why is my cat sliding his butt across the floor?
Dude.
Stop.
Wait.
What's this?
Trailblazers?
Which one is Trailblazers?
We didn't play this last time.
This is parkour and stuff.
Wait.
Another parkour?
I just got bombed.
This one has different movement types.
It's like parkour, dropper, and elytra.
Oh god.
We're so fucked.
There's a bunch of different ones.
It's all optional.
Oh, okay.
So there's hard mode...
and easy mode type deal.
There's one, two, three...
There's three games left.
This is when the multipliers start.
So this is when comeback potential is peak.
Guys, we are comebacking so hard.
It's so real.
Okay.
Lock the fuck in.
We are coming back huge.
Okay, so...
It'll explain it.
There's two types of movement.
There's one where your goal is to just complete it no matter what.
Oh, I love the full one!
Yeah, dropper.
There's also one where the goal is to do it as fast as possible.
I don't know what the comp is going to be like for this.
I have no clue who's good at parkour, who's not good at parkour.
So just do whatever you want.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dropper is the easiest probably if you do like the...
I think you guys could probably do like the middle courses.
I feel like Electro would also be like...
I don't know which one it is.
I'm confused.
So we have to finish each of them ourselves?
Or just one?
Just try.
Just try to finish the best you can and stuff.
Oh, we have to finish them all.
You don't have to finish...
Finish them as much as you can pretty much.
As much as you would like.
So start with what you're comfortable with.
So like if you did dropper and I did dropper, it'll just get whoever has the best time?
It's fine.
Both of us will get it.
So just get whatever you're super comfortable with.
I'm going to do the time trials because there's bonuses for that.
You guys, I would do like droppers.
The skill level has been brought down.
So you can try like intermediates I think should be fine.
You can try like Electro as well.
Can we do intermediate and then go like...
Like do we get points if we do intermediate and advanced?
Or just one of them?
Yeah, you can just do...
There's multiple levels per hold.
All of them and get points for all of them?
Yeah, there's multiple levels per hold.
Try this.
Come on, intermediate dropper, baby!
If there's any questions, just shout and I will try it.
What the fuck is this?
I'm so confused.
Wait, where do we drop on?
You have to land in water.
Land in water, yeah.
Oh!
Okay, yeah, that's...
I needed that explanation.
Oh, okay.
Because I was like, where are we supposed to drop?
Okay, dropping dropper is hard.
Alright, who should drop TipTip?
Oh shit, okay.
Yeah, I'm down.
I keep hitting things!
I'm going to scream.
How do we leave?
I don't want to do this one.
There should be a button in your inventory where you can leave.
It should be like the red door thing.
Oh shit, wait, no.
I'm so tired.
Where am I?
I get it now.
Why does it keep on making me go through the fucking parkour one?
Are you jumping in the parkour?
Accidentally, it keeps on like, putting me back.
Ah, I see.
Ah shit, okay.
This is difficult.
What?
So, how's your guys' day going?
Pretty good, yeah.
It's pretty cold, I'm literally boating on top of ice right now.
But, you know, for the rest it's been great.
I'm fucking good at ice boating!
Why is the gold fucking course like even...
Bro, what the fuck?
Yeah, fuck this dropper thing.
Yeah, no, the dropper was hard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go to Lichen, that shit, man.
Let me try an easier dropper.
Let's see, let's see.
No, too easy.
Easy is very easy.
Is it too easy?
Oh shit.
How come there's three check marks?
Can you do it again and again?
Uh...
Oh, it really isn't that easy, huh?
There's multiple levels, sorry.
Wait, what?
Actually, fucking Triton.
I like Triton.
Can you do it in parkour?
Hell yeah.
Oh my god, this is crazy.
Course 3, yeah, we fucking ball, bro.
Oh my gosh.
These are, like, really hard.
What the fuck?
I thought it was a pole-ass pole!
Not just a fucking thing.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, that is hard.
Oh shit.
The parkour is hard, too.
The intermediate one.
Yeah, I don't like doing the parkour, that shit is hard.
I think I need one more.
Fuck!
God damn.
I can't do the last jump for this one.
Which difficulty are you guys going for right now?
Intermediate parkour.
I'm doing the dropper.
I think...
Yeah, if it's too hard, you can just leave and you can try one lower.
I did the expert for droppers.
Perfect.
I'll do one more and then...
Ah, fuck!
I don't know exactly, like, how hard everything is.
I'm just trying to...
Yeah, this one.
Some of these are really hard.
God damn, yeah.
That makes sense.
Even, like, intermediate is super hard for a beginner.
Or, like, for a rookie player.
And, like, I do a lot of parkour, too.
So, it's like...
Yeah, don't get, like, a parkour citizen, bro.
It's kind of crazy.
I don't think I can do this.
This one's fucking hard.
Holy shit.
Let me go...
Uh...
Try it again, but probably the first...
Course 2?
No way.
I don't think I can do the fucking Electra.
I'm just doing the beginner one.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh, I'm just fucking up entirely.
I'm just gonna do all the beginner ones just for the points.
I just realized I should've just done that instead.
What the fuck I was doing earlier.
Yeah, this one is just kind of going for whatever you're most comfortable with.
Goddamn, I'm jumping too hard.
Kind of just explore.
Whoops.
This is for you to realize what you're good at, basically.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
I can actually aim for this one.
But doing the dropper makes me, like, do movements in real life.
No, same, same, same.
I literally jumped too.
I completed 10 already.
Nice.
I'm just farming Electra right now.
I think intermediate is pretty doable.
For, like, everybody.
Goddamn.
What the fuck just happened?
Oh my god.
Beginner?
Electra?
This is crazy.
Okay, no, this is not it.
This is not it.
No way, no way.
I think this is my first time hitting this, too.
Oh,
wow, we still have, like, 7 minutes left.
What the fuck?
Yeah, it's pretty generous, huh?
There's a lot of room to play.
Oh, okay.
Guys, I've never done Trident before.
Trident's fun, it's just hard.
Yeah, I normally don't even use Trident for regular Minecraft.
What's obstacles?
That's, like, block placing.
Block placing?
Aim high?
Place blocks to go across, like, a course.
I think that one might be a little tricky.
What?
Okay.
I'll do, like, one more of this.
I would recommend doing the easier parkours.
Maybe, like, the intermediates I think could be good.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, a lot of intermediates.
I think I can do advanced.
Alright.
How's there more?
Wait, what?
Oh, it's over here.
The music's banger, though.
I'm, like, in love with the fucking soundtrack.
It's really good.
A lot of work put into it.
Oh, that was... okay.
I did advanced.
I just... I can't really, like, gauge easily how hard something is.
I think...
I'm just simply too good.
Okay, that's not what I meant.
Yeah, I think, like...
I think if I played this again, I'd definitely be better, but, like, as a person who hasn't played it before, it's definitely, like...
Okay, advanced on.
The non-beginner ones are really difficult.
This is hard.
All the non-beginner ones are really difficult.
You can farm the EZs.
I think...
I think that's just me not knowing the rules of it, too.
What's obstacle?
Block placing.
Yeah, I really want to participate again.
This shit's fun.
Oh my god, fuck me.
Sorry, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Demi doesn't want Haka to play again.
Demi's like, no, please!
Fuck, not again!
Not this guy again!
Oh my god, I keep fucking up!
I'm actually gonna lose.
Oh, we're fourth place, EP?
Me going through it.
Oh, block placement is...
What?
Yeah, you have to place the block.
I hear a yay, that's good.
Okay, we're going up a lot.
I'm farming parkour right now.
He's doing everything.
Wow!
And you're so humble.
Sorry, my bad.
Nah, it's okay.
Jesus Christ.
I'm just that good.
Team effort.
I'm just doing a lot of effort.
Let's go, baby!
17 completed, let's go.
Bro, I'm so getting that doki sub, bro, it's insane.
This fucking guy.
I'm so getting that doki sub, bro.
I'm so ready.
Ah!
I've never done these block placements before.
It's such a weird mechanic.
Yeah.
They're pretty niche to just event stuff.
I did all the parkour.
There's some gold courses as well, which spawn in the middle of the map.
I guess I'm just going to go for...
Yeah, I think you could probably do that, because I think it's like intermediate.
So it should be easy.
You know what, I'm going to try the dropper again.
Dropper is really easy.
Just move your thingy to like...
Just make your FOV 30 and you should be fine.
Okay.
Hacks?
No, this is strats.
Oh my god.
Why is red team cooking so hard again?
What the fuck?
I'm sad.
I made it so far.
Okay, I did all the hard droppers as well.
I can try obstacles as well.
Me at college, a hard dropper.
Hello guys.
You're so quiet.
How are you?
Hello!
What happened?
Fuck this.
I'm out.
I was muted for a while.
I was tryharding.
Okay, let me do the trident.
Honestly, do easy droppers.
They're free points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just did them.
Puta!
Puta madre.
Wait, I'm not even done yet?
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh my days.
Oh my fucking god.
I'm sorry.
Yep, you just turned British.
What the hell then?
Oh my fucking god.
Oh my fucking god, brother.
Oh, there we go.
Perfect.
How do I get to this side?
Oh.
So, have you guys missed me?
Please say yes.
Oh yeah, I did.
No, I was muted and tryharding for a while.
Oh.
I don't know how I made it without you.
Wait, you can build a... Oh my god, you can build a bridge.
I didn't know that.
Ice boat.
I'm...
Which one's easier?
Course 1 or course 2?
Uh...
I have no clue.
I just did it.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
There's no difficulties in this.
Is it better getting the gold speed and stuff?
Does that give you more points?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yo, Lyne, someone called you British on my stream.
Oi, bruv, innit?
You wanna fall in gold?
You wanna fall in fight, man.
Can I do this already?
I don't remember.
When the course is open for the thingy, can you just do it again?
Oh, that was so sick.
Oh, I just fumbled so bad.
Uh, if the course is...
You want me?
You need to look at the little circles for the levels and see what color they're at.
Oh my god, I'm such a gamer.
You're about to cry.
I'm such a gamer.
This shit is so ass.
I'm actually such a gamer.
If you're fast...
Ice boat is all about speed, so if you do it fast, you get more points, yeah.
I just want us to get, like, on the podium.
I just wanna be 40th, man.
Okay, let me try hard a bit more in Ice Boat.
Dude, I've lost all my podium spots.
I've got stuff for us.
Okay, there's 20 seconds left, guys.
Lock in.
I'm trying.
Goddamn, goddamn.
I lost.
Oh no, I don't know where to go.
I don't know where to go.
Okay, let me just do here.
I have three medals.
Wait, I could've just made a bridge.
What the fuck?
I could've just made a bridge?
Okay, third place is good.
That's good.
I could've just made a...
Oh, I got a medal!
Yeah, last minute, I fucking did it.
I spent so much time in the fucking block placement, never knowing I could've just made a bridge.
I could've made a bridge.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
We have a fucking gamer!
Locking in.
Nice.
Beautiful.
She really wants that third place.
We went up!
Oh my god, it's heading there.
We're slowly getting to the third place!
The thing is, right?
Like, we are actually playing for third, because one of the games left is Extraction, which is like FPS, and the fucking red team has Zekken.
Which is insane.
He's literally on Sentinel for that one.
So, hey guys, we can try our best.
I mean, I'm pretty sure Matsuyoshi is also pretty good at shooters.
Yeah, I mean...
Sneaky is literally an Overwatch pro, so...
Yeah, but Overwatch doesn't require aim, so it's chill.
Damn!
31st place!
It was the Zenyatta player, bro!
It was literally the Zen player, other than the Korean Zens, though, so...
Bro, 31st place!
Holy shit!
Oh, he's doing his climbing!
That's nine!
Where the fuck are my memberships at, huh?
We haven't won yet!
39th place!
Where the fuck are my memberships at, bro?
That's like 10 bucks for me!
We're going crazy.
By the way, it's not over yet!
It's not over yet!
We're missing, we're missing.
Oh my god, I got 39th place on the fucking... that last one.
That last one was so confusing for me.
I was so confused.
Yeah, it's a little difficult sometimes.
And you know, it's because there's so many tech stuff that I've never done before, so I was really confused.
This is fun, I like this.
Wait, my favorite part is Cookie.
This is kind of fun.
Is Blockworks like an open server to just practice?
Did you do the Electra one?
No, that's not an open server.
Oh, the Electra one was fun.
I did do Electra.
Electra was great.
Electra was fun, yeah.
Electra.
Electra, fuck.
Dude, this Cookie is like...
I kind of want to start a cult around that.
It's like talking to me.
It's talking to you?
Yeah.
It's telling you to kill your parents, kill your parents, kill your parents.
Guys, it's not last place yet, because I'm not last.
I was second last.
Yeah, to me this is a one.
We fucking won this shit, bro.
We got two ones, let's fucking go.
It's saving a win, it's a one, because we already won this shit.
Okay, is that Extraction or Blitz?
What's Blitz again?
It's a Hide and Seek.
Oh, it's a Hide and Seek.
Yeah, yeah, I bet.
Oh wait, I need to kill somebody.
What's Extraction again?
It's the FPS.
It's Rainbow Six Siege.
We're so cooked, we're so fucked.
Let me go, please.
Put me down.
We're all gamers, we should do Extraction last, though.
Yeah.
We've done Extraction last, then Red Team will have the bonus multiplier.
I'll keep it at $1.50.
Yeah, if we do Extraction first, then it's more of luck for the last multiplier.
But I think it's too late.
I think people already chose Blitz.
It is what it is.
I love Blitz Hunt.
Yeah, I don't think we would have changed the title.
Put me down.
Hide and seek time.
I'm so cooked.
Oh, they're just gonna find the toilet.
This game is actually peak content.
This is so hard because of lag, honestly.
It's peak content, though.
I mean, if you find a good corner, you can see where they are, but they can also scout you out, too, with abilities.
I'm so bad at this one, if I'm being quite honest.
Oh, good?
Nah, just lock in.
It's simple.
If you lock in, it's so simple.
Nah, I'm kidding.
It's just like, you gotta get partially lucky.
When you're hunting, you can right-click it, and it'll tell you how many people are near you.
Oh, that's new, is it?
Oh, wait, no, that's in our inventory.
Never mind.
I thought you meant we could find more of them, because it was out in the open.
Nah, it's a very quick way.
If you're running into a room, it's a very quick way to know if you need to look around.
But the cooldown's insane.
Mhm.
By the way, Wolfie, you know the other block wars, are they just normal block wars?
So this is the rookies, right?
Yeah.
This is rookies.
I don't remember the difference.
The player roster is very different.
There's, like, five minecrafters here.
Yeah, there's a lot of new people here.
It's mostly, like, non-minecraft players.
And then each team has one pro.
Okay, so what we do here is we run outwards, Hawkeye, and you find a spot to hide.
You'll see the hunters will be glowing.
You'll see us as teammates glowing as well.
We have 70 seconds to hide, too.
Dude, we can, like, jump a little higher now.
Mhm.
Shit, how do I hide?
Do I just, like...
Like, do I transform into anything?
No, no, no, no, there's no transforming.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, it's the back of my head green.
Oh, we're all together?
Oh, god.
I didn't even realize we're all together.
That's bad.
I didn't realize you guys were following me.
I was just walking.
I'm doing this stupid fucking game.
I see a peeker.
Jiggle peek around everywhere.
Oh, god.
They don't see me.
This is terrifying.
Why are they still here?
This is so terrifying.
Oh, god, they didn't see me.
Where's the other one at?
They're all gone, but I don't know why they're still here.
We're good.
I wanna move away.
I'm gonna try and get out of here.
I think we should stay here because they've already checked us, right?
So they're gonna be, like, looking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just try to, like, keep a corner and, like, move around a little bit if they're close, just to, like, make it so they can't, like, see you in their peripheral vision.
I might die.
I think he's gonna look for me.
I've been detected.
Wait, does it tell you when you're a detective?
Yeah.
I thought you said when you are a detective.
It'll tell you, like, when you're detected, yeah.
Goddamn.
Goddamn!
We're good?
I think I'm good.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good too.
I'm, like, with two other people.
I'm good.
I live.
Okay.
We should, uh... Oh, we're hunting.
This is good, this is good.
I'm going north, I'm going north, I'm going north.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
I'll go west.
Uh...
You go together with... You can come with me.
Okay.
I'm gonna look inside this room because I see people hiding in the room.
So, this will be very good.
In the room, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw somebody hide in the spawn.
That's, uh, simple.
He's just not moving.
You can just get him.
That's a free kill.
No, I think he's gonna run to the last three.
No, no, no, he's not.
He's just baiting.
Yeah, he was baiting.
Okay.
Uh, yeah, so this will be good info for us to, um, kinda know... I saw Giga, I saw Giga here.
Like, hide.
Oh.
You can, like, run around and, and, like, spot people and just, like, punch them with your sword.
Okay, with the sonar, right?
No, with your sword.
You can use the sonar as well.
Okay.
You just need to punch them with your sword.
It's a one-shot.
Um...
There is one player nearby me.
He died in the lava here?
Remember to use your ability, guys.
I see somebody here.
It's only one.
Where are these bitches?
I got one.
Hmm.
There is one player nearby.
Oh, skibbity toilet room, hold on!
What?
Skibbity toilet room?
Oh my god, you're kidding me!
Oh my god.
I got another.
Maybe you're right.
That's actually so funny.
Why am I even trying to chase this guy?
He's way too good at movement.
Skibbity toilet room is okay, though.
There's so many good hiding spots.
There's zero players.
There's zero players, okay.
No people in skibbity toilet room.
Skibbity toilet room is clear.
Are we sure?
Yeah, skibbity toilet room.
Use the sonar.
Oh my god.
He really is skibbity toilet room.
I got 14 kills, that might be a record.
Holy shit, you're insane.
Jesus.
He might be him, man.
I only killed four.
I got three.
Someone hid in spawn, you fucking idiot.
Holy shit.
Who got 14?
You know Simple?
He was in the beginning, he just hid in spawn.
He was waiting for everyone to leave.
I think he went out and then ran back in.
I think.
He ran out.
You can technically hide here, yeah.
Oh, I don't see you.
Run, run, run.
This room is so ass.
Oh, this room is ass.
Go to the skibbity toilet room.
Oh, I'm not going there right now.
Let's find out if it's actually us.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
I can go up here.
Don't go to skibbity toilet room.
I feel like people are gonna...
I might get caught.
This is a bad hiding spot.
This is L.
Gamers, don't look up.
Surely?
Wouldn't it be bold of me to...
while I'm hiding, just go pee?
Yeah.
But if you're confident enough, Loki...
Oh, who's running?
I see someone running.
They're right behind you.
There's two people.
Lead them to another person.
Oh, unlucky.
Find another person on an enemy team and lead them to it.
Who's in the basketball room?
Damn, I think we found a really good hiding spot.
Cause we're like, hiding in the obvious.
And no one's like, looking at us.
Oh, fuck, they're mine.
Okay, so what?
Who's that?
Is that Doki or Alain?
I didn't look back.
Oh, that's Doki.
You're in the basketball room.
Yeah.
Why did I do that, dude?
Why am I actually so fucking dumb?
Nah, nah, you're good.
It was funny.
No, dude, the other person that was like, like, with me is still alive.
Oh, my days.
Wait.
Oh, god.
Oh, no, they found Alain.
There's ten seconds left.
Ten seconds.
Hold on.
Fourteen, fourteen, fourteen.
Bro, is he blind?
Guys, I'm really shit at this game.
Holy shit.
I saved that guy.
Oh, never mind, never mind.
Bro!
Bro, how did line do it?
That's huge.
That's crazy.
Okay.
I win.
I just came back.
Bro, you did.
You did.
Two fuckers literally walked in front of you.
That's insane.
I have to go to the bathroom, man.
South is one where you can run through pretty easily.
So that might be a good one.
Who's gonna go just to the side?
Oh, I don't like that one.
What's over here?
Oh, this one.
Wait, roof gang, hold up.
There might be a roof here that we can sit on.
There is a roof.
This is so huge.
Oh, let's get the team.
Hold on.
Yeah, hold strong, hold strong.
I might die to this one.
This one I fucked up.
This might be the strat, actually.
They won't see you.
This is a bad one.
I went to a bad room.
Gamers, just don't look up.
No, we're good, Demis.
We're good.
Gamers, don't look up.
Yeah, they don't look up.
There's so many people here that...
Bro, bro, bro, bro.
He's F5, Demi.
He's not looking up.
He didn't look up.
He didn't look up, and he hasn't seen it.
He hasn't seen us, and he's gone.
And he's alive.
That's it, bro.
No way.
Oh, god.
This guy's gonna manifest pissing himself right now.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm the anchor in this game.
Nah, you're good.
Nah, bro, no one's heavier to me.
Oh, they killed three yellows.
They killed three yellows.
You can't anchor in hide-and-seek.
It's a team effort.
Hey, we're having fun.
Oh, really?
Is it like individual score or something?
Sorry, yeah.
It is full individual, but like...
It's chill.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, Hunter coming in.
Will they see it?
He knows.
He's not going up here, though.
He doesn't know.
We're so good.
Bro!
Yo!
Yay!
Our full team survived?
Yeah, blue also survived, too.
Blue survived.
Crazy!
Um, I think...
Am I gonna do it again?
Yes, but in the other side.
East.
I'm going east.
Maybe south and then to the left.
I'm fine with lion shoe.
Lion shoe's insane in this game.
I have a crazy hiding spot in this room specifically, but it works like only half the time.
I'm coming for you.
What the fuck is this?
Not this one.
Oh, wait.
I might know this room.
I'm gonna gamble it.
I'm still gonna gamble it.
I fucked up.
I'm gonna gamble it.
There's too many people here.
There's no way.
I'm gonna gamble it.
No, this is a GG spot, guys.
I fucked up my hiding spot.
I've been detected, but I have not been killed, though.
The map changed and I didn't know.
Oh, they found me.
Shit.
God damn it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Damn.
Micro movements.
Feinberg on the teal.
Holy shit.
I died.
I panicked.
Micro fucking movements.
They won't see it.
Please.
To be fair, it's really hard to not see it.
This one's very hard.
I just imagine people jumping and being like, oh shit, I don't see anything.
They can easily miss it.
Are you kidding me?
This is a really good spot.
I'm gonna scout.
Dude, I'm...
I'm behind a one-by-one block.
You guys are so fucking good at hiding.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
Yeah, the IRS will never get me, bro.
What happened to the other guy that was with me?
I already died, man.
Oh no, they got found.
They know about the spots, probably.
In seconds.
Yeah, it's crazy.
All I had to do was micro tap around this block when they saw me almost.
Oh, hello.
Oh god, the whole squad's running up.
I've just been rotating left and right.
Yay!
We're so good.
Oh, the guy with me died?
That's funny.
I'm on track for point record right now.
Hold on.
Oh, go south.
I have a crazy spot.
Trust.
South?
Okay.
Oh wait, no, he knows.
Whatever, man.
Fuck it.
South?
He just doesn't go this way.
Surely.
Follow me.
Over here.
Ladder.
No, Feinberg literally made this, dude.
This is mine.
Don't worry.
He was just on my team last time.
Where?
There's a trapdoor.
Shift on the trapdoor.
Here?
Like this?
To the back of the wall and then shift on top again.
I'm worried that Feinberg's up here.
Oh, fuck, I fell down.
Just, just, just, just hold.
Is that Feinberg?
That might be Feinberg.
He's coming.
He's on his way up.
I'm in mid.
I'm in the middle.
And run for your dear life.
I got locked in.
I'm doing so badly.
I'm gonna stay here.
I'm so scared.
There's no way they're gonna find me here.
There's the piss trap.
Come on, line.
Give me your blessing.
Piss on me.
I knew it.
This one.
The Mr. Krabs one.
They love this one.
We have to, like, jump here.
There's so many new rooms.
Yeah, if I can see them, they can't see me.
I should've done it.
I feel like, I feel like He wouldn't expect, like, somebody to know it.
Do you know what I'm talking about, Wolfie?
In the McDonald's thingy?
I just did a gamer move.
I'll be honest.
Dude, I just...
No way, no way, no way.
Shit, shit, shit.
Point record is possibly lost.
9, 8, 6, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1, I made it!
I did an actual insane gamer move.
I dodged two people.
They're on my corner.
Bro, they went behind me twice.
I'm gonna go north.
That was crazy.
Wait, red team isn't lost right now.
Surely, surely we close.
Just don't let them kill you.
South again?
I kinda wanna go south again.
Fuck, fuck.
Oh, this might be roof gang again.
It's roof gang.
Okay, roof gang time.
Sit on the roof, believe.
I think I fucked up this one for sure.
I found Jobart.
I feel like this is so obvious.
Like, this one, this one.
Wait, you guys have some height too.
I don't know what room that is.
I'm gonna go this one.
I don't like when people are with me.
Peeta.
I think they're gonna find me.
Nah, we're good.
I see two people.
Oh, okay, I see the rest of you now.
They're like all at the same side of the map.
This spot might actually be kinda goated.
People are going away from me.
It must be my aura.
My gamer aura.
Your piss aura.
Oh, somebody's swinging.
Okay, we're good.
They've entered.
No, they have not entered.
Are they entering?
They're entering now.
It's rain.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't know there was a ladder there.
Hello?
I didn't realize you were above me.
I've been detected, but no one's kinda close to me.
Oh, it's over here.
I see.
I didn't know there was a ladder there.
That's crazy.
Actually, it kinda goes far.
Why is all of them in this fucking room?
Get out of here.
Fuck off.
Thank you.
Noki's clutching up.
Huge.
Bro, bro, bro, bro.
Who's over here in the back?
Is that Haka?
Yes.
Oh, this spot's crazy.
Wait a minute.
No!
I got fucking bombed by the other guy.
Fucking cheats.
We're still doing great.
No, the one round I got caught.
This is the only round I got caught because I had that person with me.
Bro, that spot is insane.
One more round.
That spot is crazy.
The other guy got me caught.
Oh, I'm mad.
Oh, I know where I'm going.
There's one spot east.
It's a bit of a nasty one.
I'll go with you.
Yeah, yeah.
So in here.
In here.
Take the ladder over here.
Then up.
Small jump here and then on this pillar.
Right here.
I think I'm...
Oh, this is a bad spot.
Fingers crossed.
That's disgusting.
I might be the first one caught.
Fingers crossed.
Oh god, I can't see shit.
I can't see shit.
I'm shifting.
First F5.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Who's that on the right in the corner?
I have no idea.
Oh, Anthos.
Wait, how does he...
Oh, is he playing on F5?
How did he know?
Oh, that's a fucking Minecraft...
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
The other hunters don't play on F5.
That makes sense.
Who's that Widow?
Minecrafters.
I think so.
Oh man, finally.
Guys, it's W-Rate.
Yay!
Wait, somebody left a call.
Yeah, Lineshoe's not in the VC though.
Okay, just ignore the heartbeat.
They won't find us.
Yup, they won't see us.
Yup, they won't look.
Oh my god, oh my god.
That's so scary.
Why are all of you guys in here?
It's a great spot.
Dude, it's such a good spot.
You put everything onto that.
It's fine, it's fine.
They won't look up, they just won't look up.
Oh, Lines did.
They really just won't look up.
And they're like, oh, where are they?
Oh, wow, I can't find them.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Oh, he can't find us.
What?
He actually did it.
Oh my god.
That is crazy.
Dude, what?
Bro.
No way.
That was insane.
That's insane?
The fact that he didn't look up, that's... yeah.
No way, what the fuck?
How did he know?
He didn't have F5.
I bumped into the one hunter that had F5 on.
Whoa.
That's so unlucky.
Crazy.
Holy fuck.
First place!
Yeah!
Oh my god, we have one more game to be third.
There's hope.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm getting my strepsils.
We gotta be able to FPS.
Oh my god.
That's where you lose me, bro.
There's hope.
We don't flank.
Okay, I think we should stick together.
Because I remember the last time we tried one person flank and the other stick together.
Where's Lion?
Is Lion pissing again?
I don't know where Lion is.
I saw him moving.
He's moving right now.
Oh my god, I was top 10 on the last one.
Nice.
Unlucky.
Alright, alright, alright.
What's the spot?
21st, baby!
21st!
Comeback of the fucking century!
Holy shit, bro.
That's the last game, Haka.
You gotta go to the other side.
You're in the last game.
9th, okay.
We did really good, Doki.
You got 9th.
Yeah, I just fucked up the last two.
The last one.
Because I bumped into Cam.
Damn.
Constellation tree.
Our hope here is that we...
So, slight problem.
The last game is an FPS game.
And red team is an FPS team.
And yellow team has FPS players.
So we have to clutch up.
It's fine.
We're so fucked.
We're so fucked, bro.
We need to outsmart them somehow.
Come on.
Top 3, baby.
Top 3.
I believe in us.
I don't know how we're gonna outsmart them when one of our teammates can't hear our comms.
But we'll figure it out.
My dance lesson teacher was like, Where are you?
And I didn't realize what time it is.
I didn't realize.
She cancelled the lesson on me.
I don't think even if we started on time, I would have made it.
I would have made it.
Fuck extraction.
It is crazy that we're in range to potentially make finals after the first game.
I didn't know what time it was.
I was looking at the clock.
I thought it was over.
I was so confused why it ended.
I just texted back.
I was like, I'm sorry.
A couple hundred points range from second.
Oh, this is a different map.
Do we split up or play together?
Because I remember it depends on the map itself.
I think the best idea is to go teams.
Three go right and the rest go to the flank.
Because the best way is to sandwich them.
But it's also map dependent.
It depends on what this map is.
Last time we tried sticking together and it didn't work.
We had to add two flanking and the others...
The main thing is we have to pick them off before they pick us off.
I think the weaker players might have to stick together.
Yeah.
The gamers are the ones who go for flank.
Who thinks they're a second frag for this?
They're what?
Second frag.
I don't know.
Is it right click?
Yeah.
This is the same as photon.
We can check in the first round and see who's the best.
The second best.
I'll try to play...
I'm trying to think how I approach this.
Because I think if you...
This map is so colorful.
It's really big for an extraction map.
There's a lot of angles.
You gotta be very careful.
There's so many angles.
Wait, what the fuck?
This might just be deathmatch.
This might be gun game.
What you have to look out for is just from spawn, look at the places.
What's swap all pen?
You can see the pings maybe?
How do you ping?
Which is F by default.
I don't see it.
F?
Okay.
Maybe the game needs to start to do it.
It's right click.
Do you mean you reload?
I forgot to reload.
No, no, no reload.
It doesn't automatically.
Where do I go?
Loki, me, Rekka go right, Rez go left.
Nami and Wolfie go left.
I'll grab the smoke bomb and mid.
Or you can grab it too.
Us three gotta be careful.
I don't think it's a good idea.
Who are we playing against?
Who am I going with?
You went right I guess.
I forgot about the auto charge.
There's a yellow guy in mid.
We need to be careful.
Right side is clear I think?
Right side, I don't see it.
They're left side.
I hit one.
I'm trying to take long angles.
See if that'll help.
I'm gonna try and flank.
They're on top.
They're coming from the left.
I'm going flank.
They're all here.
I'm dead.
I'm good.
I'm running back.
They're all behind me.
I'm okay.
There's one on top.
What?
Okay, got one.
They're all on top.
Anthos here is low.
I'm one hit.
One on you.
I got one.
This is a Valorant team.
It's 1v2.
You see them.
They're glowing.
I think one of them has to be at least 2 HP.
Oh shit.
I didn't know where the...
That was just me?
I thought it meant...
I didn't realize it was just me.
You were saying we're 2v1.
Oh, that's good.
Red team swept though.
That's fine.
Learning experience.
I didn't realize it was just me left.
I think I can be second frag.
Because I got...
Play with at least one teammate.
And then I will scout a little bit.
Needing the health up?
They like going above.
Should we go above too?
This is a different team.
They're all right side.
I got one.
They're on top.
Fuck.
Got me.
I'm boosting.
No.
I...
There's one.
I got booster.
I'm at 2 HP left.
Where's spawn?
There's spawn.
I got one.
Both of them are spawn.
I'll spawn.
Don't die.
I got one.
One left.
In mid.
Going to spawn.
On top.
Be careful.
I'm down.
I got her.
Shift in mid.
Hold shift in mid.
Extracting.
Beautiful.
We got points though.
Comets.
That's the FPS team.
We gotta get high ground.
I'm going right side to get the health up.
I'll follow you, Wolfie.
Okay.
I'm gonna go mid.
And just peek around.
See where they are.
It's fine.
I hit two.
I hit three.
One guy is 1 HP.
Two right side.
They're in the middle.
There's one person in the middle.
I'm flanking.
Dude, sleeping caught me.
Holy shit.
Yeah, she has one.
I can't beat fucking Senzeken.
Reign is one.
Okay, one's...
Oh, there they are.
I got one HP.
One low mid, one top mid.
Turn around.
Oh, fuck.
Nice one, Shu.
Good damage or kills.
Just try.
Oh my god.
Is it points or extraction?
Both.
There's kill points.
There's damage points.
There's extracting points.
And there's round win points.
All good that we play for third here.
That's the goal.
Let's go.
We just got...
The teams that I thought were gonna do better have done better.
Which is fine.
That doesn't sound encouraging when you say it like that.
I'm gonna say it like I didn't go in expecting to win.
I'm going left for heals.
Okay, I'll go middle again.
Okay.
It's been nice to scout everything out a little bit.
Oh, YOLO lost last round.
I think scouting is the best thing so we know where they are.
Oh, you're going with me again?
Oh god.
Okay.
What do you mean oh god?
What do you say like that?
Wait, they went extraction.
They're literally going extraction.
One guy went extracted.
Oh, they're all...
Early, early, early left side.
Wait, what if I do that too?
Kill their ass, kill their ass, kill their ass.
Oh shit, I should have done that.
Okay, Feinberg's left I think.
Wait, that guy is one, yeah.
Okay, thanks.
It's just Feinberg.
I don't know where he's at.
Oh, middle, middle, middle.
Nice.
I saw one of them extract.
I was like, I'm gonna do that too.
That is insane.
They got one extraction.
Like go in the middle and just like straight up extract.
I killed somebody.
Problem.
We're just preying on yellow team's downfall.
And blue.
I think yellow team is not doing as good as you thought they would.
Oh, they're third right now.
Yeah.
They're still third.
There's no points on the tab list.
Yeah, it's like yellow is doing the best.
Yellow is doing the best.
They have 5-0'd.
Holy shit.
It's all good.
Okay, I'm gonna go...
Left side.
Oh, I'm mid.
Someone get the extra HP.
Left or right?
Yeah, I'll go right.
Whoever's going right.
Okay, left.
People are left.
Go back.
I'm just pushing their spawn.
They're on top.
They're on top and mid.
Shot one.
Wait, do you not charge your phone while you're using it?
I forgot to plug it in.
There's the other one.
I died.
They're on top.
They're right there.
No, he got me.
Shit.
I'm dead.
It's just you.
Okay.
Unlucky.
Unlucky, yeah.
Alright.
Oh, dude.
Whoever I was fighting was really good.
Who killed you?
I don't know.
Sandwichlord.
Yeah, he fucked me up there.
He's crazy.
Alright.
Why am I spawning mid?
I need my health up.
I was so used to it.
Okay, we can beat the knights.
I believe.
I'll grab the smoke.
Get the thingy, Wolf.
I got it.
I don't think there's anyone left side.
I'm gonna go all the way around.
Oh, they're on top.
They're right behind me.
They're in spawn.
They went all the way back.
They're all together.
I shot Point Crow.
Shit, it's on the roof.
How the fuck did they go over here?
They all went together.
Misty.
Oh my god, the whole squad there.
I got Vinny.
I hit two on Vinny.
That was a crazy snipe.
Extracting!
Point Crow on me.
Let's go.
I got him.
No, I died.
You extracted?
I got one.
Last one.
Nice.
Extract.
Believe.
Huge.
Let's go.
I also have my smoke still.
We're fourth now.
Or have we always been fourth?
I don't remember.
The points are hidden.
Oh.
It's the last round.
I'm going to get HP.
Believe.
I might be gay.
HP?
Right behind you.
Watch out.
I'm backing a little bit.
It's the Among Us skin, bro.
I'm backing up a little bit.
Careful.
Oh, unlucky.
I smoked too hard there.
Where the hell?
Oh, there.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm fucking dead.
I was going to throw a smoke.
Come on.
Huge.
Oh, no.
You guys.
You got this.
I got one of them.
Peter Griffin's coming.
Gigas on the top of the extraction point.
Yes, I got him.
I got two kills.
I got two points for us there.
Gigas extraction.
All right.
We did all right.
Pretty solid performance.
I got nine kills.
How many damage?
I have nine kills.
36 damage.
Nine kills, 32 hits.
Large?
Yeah.
Three hits.
Beautiful.
We clucked two on top.
Oh, hell no, bro.
Score break not done.
Third place or fourth?
Third or fourth?
Let's go third or fourth.
Oh, man.
I'm so glad we don't have to reload.
Because the last time we were reloading was so fucking...
Dang it.
Lovely Patreons.
Yeah.
Oh, shout out to all those Patreons.
Yeah, shout out to them.
Oh my God, Feinberg's a Patreon?
Shout out to my boy, Doofs.
That's how he gets in every time.
Totally.
Guys, we did it.
We're not last.
Dude, Astro's fifth time.
Wait, no, these are individuals.
This is top ten points.
Oh, I was gonna say.
The team is called Astro?
Whoa, Sleepy got seventh.
Holy moly.
Come on, our boy Wolfie.
Yeah, this is mine.
Is it fourth?
Are you fourth?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh, Feinberg's third.
Crazy.
Who's second or first?
I've never seen Feinberg play before.
Oh, I killed him in the last round.
Yeah, he might be first, but I killed him in the extraction.
Yo, 39th, baby.
Let's go.
Wait, really?
39th.
Yay, 20th.
For us not being able to do the first game, that's pretty good.
We lost the entire first game.
Sixth place, okay, okay.
Hey, pretty good, though.
Eighth, fifth, though, yeah.
I think if we had the first game, we would've been fourth.
Yeah, no, 100%.
Yeah.
So this is blue, probably, I think.
Versus...
Who's left?
It's either red or...
Oh, it's Comets versus...
It's either blue or orange.
Hold on.
With 12,902 points.
Oh, okay, okay.
This is, uh...
Sandwich Lord.
Oh.
That's Blanche's choice out of five.
Okay, so this is the...
Sleepy and Rain team...
versus the, like...
Nintendo speedrunner team, I think.
Nintendo speedrunner?
That team is fucking stacked!
What the fuck?
The Nintendo speedrunners are crazy!
They're all rounders!
Yeah, me.
What's up, Heavenly?
What's up?
That's crazy you lost like that.
Shut the fuck up, man!
Why is there Hoogie, like, a fucking Doombot?
No, the fucking bomb monster from Doom.
There's no way he did that.
Damn.
Disrespectful, dude.
The disrespect is insane?
Oh my god, he left the whole server.
This is gonna be an interesting, uh...
thingy.
Interesting.
There's no way, because... Oh, wait, I just remembered.
This is a Valorant game, so...
GG's to red.
I guess.
I mean, we'll see.
Like, blue team's been cooking the entire event.
So this might be close.
No, they all play, like, all FPS, so...
Red is, like...
Red is, like, majority FPS, though.
I hope they take it.
Because, uh...
Sleepy and Red have been dealt dirty.
They have been, like, wanting to win so bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
Okay, we're good.
So...
First place team gets to pick, like, what site they want to be on.
If they want to, like, start attack or start defense.
I want Red team to win.
I feel like attacking is so much easier.
Uh, I mean, the map's been slightly weak the last time we played.
So then, I think it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't actually remember what the lag issue was last time, but it has been fixed.
The guy who was 1v1ing was not an FPS player, because he fucking pushed me in a Valorant game, which is, like, the most stupid thing you could ever do.
The first rule of Valorant is that if you have the advantage, you don't push.
You just stay.
Until they push you, because then you have the free file.
Thank you for playing.
It was a lot of fun.
No worries, dude.
Thank you so much for joining.
Yeah, it was nice meeting you.
Fuck, I'm so angry.
Okay, thank you for playing.
See you guys later.
Bye!
Bye-bye!
Oh, hold on.
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
They're getting fucked.
They're actually getting fucked over.
I'm not gonna lie, blue team is, like, peeking out in the open.
Wait, actually, no.
No, they're fine.
They're fine.
Yeah, like, the Valorant players are playing Valorant.
Yeah, the thing is that the thing is that they didn't kill the Valorant players there.
The Valorant players literally just waited and then revived.
No, this is Valorant.
You can see the Valorant players literally just peeking.
Dude, that was crazy.
Yeah, that's why when he was, like, telling me to push, I didn't push because I knew I had the advantage because, like, I literally just had to wait until the bomb goes off.
So I was, like, when I was hearing push, I was just like, no, the bomb's gonna take down.
It doesn't matter.
They have no time to defuse.
I don't disagree with you.
They literally, they have...
Let's see.
They know what to do.
They just play slow.
That's why I fucking hate Valorant.
You just play slow and you win.
I have no patience for that.
Really?
Okay, who's the Valorant player?
I don't know.
Who's, like, the main Valorant player?
Like, she peeked in the open, so...
That's why.
Look, they already planted the bomb so they don't have to worry.
They just need to guard the bomb.
Oh, never mind.
Oh!
Wait a minute.
I did not expect...
I did not expect that to happen.
Blue takes his round.
Yeah.
Nuke?
Is it nuke?
Uh, no.
Oh, I had to turn around.
I don't remember.
This does not look like nuke.
B site's inferno, I think.
This does not look like...
B site's inferno.
I don't remember what...
A site might be cash, but I could be wrong.
I'm sad.
I missed my dance lessons today.
I feel bad.
My teacher was like, where are you?
And I was like, I'm sorry.
I told her I'd be late too.
But I didn't realize how late I was gonna be.
I've been up.
I'm up.
I was even, like, timing the set schedule.
Like, session.
Surprisingly enough.
Hold on.
Oh, Sandwich is down now.
The blue team carry is down.
Oh, Shira's, like, reviving.
I was like, I'm sorry.
Wait.
Guys, I'm not lying.
I'm up.
Oh, they're just fucking running.
They don't care.
They're just swarming.
This is crazy.
Hold on.
No, I didn't dox myself too.
This was a dance teacher that I didn't dox myself to.
So she doesn't know who I am.
I'm just kind of watching red, like, move across the map.
Oh, they're splitting.
Okay.
Alright.
Where's Zek?
Was his name Zekko?
I can tell you that.
No.
They're playing.
Oh, they're defending.
Oh, what a shot.
Beautiful.
It's a final right now.
They're all fighting.
Like, blasted teams.
Who's the other guy?
Oh, there he is.
Blue needs to, like, push here, because they need to plant, I think.
Wait, who's attacking?
Blue needs to, like, plant there, like, bomb.
How are they playing this?
Red's got it on lock.
I know Sleepy is, like, what's the second highest rank in Valorant?
Because I know he's that rank.
I guess this is a red team set game, no?
That was so cocky.
Literally, they could just push him.
He told me he was, like, immortal.
Yeah, I know Sleepy is immortal.
Is he immortal?
Is the second highest immortal?
Is the one below top 500?
Okay.
Because I know he's that rank.
Sleepy is, like, immortal in Valorant.
Because I remember last time I talked to him, he was immortal.
Red's on the attack.
Yes, they have the world champion and also an immortal Valor player.
Wait, hold on.
Who's... Oh, Zekken's, like, full-pushing mid.
What the fuck?
He's that confident.
He's got that dog in him.
He knows he's got that world championship under his belt.
They're all on B.
Do they know how to...
Do they know they need to play?
Oh, Sean's got it.
Huge.
Oh, the flank.
Oh, the flank's been shut down.
I think Red takes it.
That's overconfidence there.
Nevermind, nevermind, nevermind.
Oh, he still got it.
Yay!
GG.
That was a fast one.
That was super fast.
I mean... Holy shit.
Sense it up.
Not only did they win the Valor championships, they also won Rookies 3.
Put that in their Liquipedia right now.
Is there Liquipedia for Minecraft?
Bye, guys.
GG's.
That was fun, yeah.
GG's, everybody.
GG's.
It was nice meeting you.
Yeah.
GG's, guys.
It was nice talking to you again, Doki.
Yeah.
You're 39th place?
39th place?
Yeah, what the fuck, bro?
What's my subscription?
Alright, I'll subscribe to you.
Wait, are you gonna subscribe to me?
I can literally check.
I am!
I literally get your fucking shorts all the fucking time.
I even get notifications for your fucking shorts.
Oh, thanks, man.
Yeah, but I don't see a comment on it.
How was I supposed to know?
Bro, what the fuck am I gonna be commenting them on, man?
I like that.
Give me one comment so I'll know if you're actually subscribed.
Give me one.
GG's, guys.
GG's, I'll subscribe to you after this.
GG's.
Alright, everyone.
Thank you for having me.
I would love to participate again.
This was really fun.
Yeah, thank you.
Bye-bye.
That was fun.
Membership.
Yeah, that was fun.
I had to change my mindset of how it was gonna go after the first game, because I was like, oh, wait, this is not as competitive.
The first one was super competitive, so I was like, okay, how are we feeling here?
I think it didn't help that I was also very introverted there, too.
I think I got more comfortable as the games go on.
Wait, let me...
I don't know if I'm supposed to still go to dance class.
Are you still free today for a lesson?
I just finished work.
It went overtime because people were late.
40 minutes late to start the session.
People were late.
I really want...
I really want to go to dance lessons.
Please.
She's still charging me for money for it.
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
I definitely timed things wrong there.
I don't want to be like...
Sorry, teacher.
I was playing Minecraft.
Sorry.
I don't want to say that.
That's sad.
She knows I stream.
She was asking me...
She was like, I don't want to pry too much because...
I don't want to pry too much because I don't know if you want to be private about what you do.
I was like, do you watch streamers?
She was like, yeah.
I love SlimeSicle.
I think she's a Minecrafter.
That is exactly why I don't say who I am because I think she might know.
She was like, yeah, my favorite streamers are SlimeSicle and Jslatt.
Which, to be fair, Jslatt started off as a Minecrafter, but now he's like super variety.
But I'm pretty sure...
I think SlimeSicle is like full of Minecrafter, right?
Is that... No, she doesn't know.
She doesn't know.
SlimeSicle and Jslatt is not here!
They're not even in this fucking lobby!
She doesn't know.
She doesn't fucking know.
I never told her.
Like, even the songs we use to do the dance lessons, it's like the original songs.
So like, Mint and I haven't recorded the songs yet.
So we're just dancing to the original.
So like, I'm just hoping that like, I don't think I'm going to tell her who I am.
She just knows that I'm a...
She knows that I may or may not be a big streamer.
That's really it.
Or not big!
Just like a...
Just a streamer.
I just told her that I have... I do a lot.
I work with... I have a lot of work stuff.
And that like...
I'm not gonna tell her!
I'm not... Okay, the other dance teacher I accidentally doxed myself.
So she like...
She like subscribed to my YouTube channel, and now her children knows what I do.
So like, that was a little oopsie.
Cause her children were like, oh my god!
Doki Bridge, she's famous!
And she was telling me about it.
And I was like, oh fuck, okay.
That's...
So luckily, her kids don't know what I look like.
Like outside.
They don't know that I'm truly a tomato on the inside.
They just know that I look like this.
So luckily, her kids don't.
Cause apparently her daughter...
You know what?
I'm low-key like...
Hey!
The daughter of the dance teacher, if you're watching this right now, I know you're a gay.
Apparently her... the dance teacher was like, oh...
So if you're watching this, the child of my dance teacher is watching this right now.
She was like...
She was like really wanted to show her kid me.
Because she was like, oh, my daughter, she's a gamer too.
Like, oh my god.
She loves playing like video games and stuff.
And she's like, should I get her?
Like, oh yeah, what's the difference between a Mac and a PC?
Why do gamers like using PCs?
And I'm like, because graphically, it's better.
And there's more games on PC.
And she's like, yeah, my daughter, she's been asking me to get her a PC.
And I was so surprised because I was like, but Mac's more expensive.
Why would you want a PC?
And then, I was just like, well, there's games on PC.
And like, graphically wise, it's just better.
Like, you usually use Mac for like, editing or like, music and stuff.
So like, anyway, so her daughter knows who I am now.
So, if you're watching this, you're...
If you're watching this, don't tell anyone, buddy, like...
Don't tell people what province and city we are in.
Like a child, I swear to God, child, if you...
Oh, I know where you live.
Just remember, child, I know where you live.
Don't keep chill.
The river stops.
Not absurd by the way.
It's jokey threatening a child.
Mutually assured destruction.
Anyway, so my other dance teacher, the one I missed a session today,
um...
I am...
Actually, no, I'm not planning on telling her, because like she was like, oh my God, you like League?
She's like, a semi-gamer.
She's like, oh yeah, I love playing...
I know, that's a...
There's no saving her, but she likes playing League and was talking about Arcane and stuff to me, and I was like, oh fuck, because I'm friends with people who are like League streamers, or like, well known in the League streaming community, so I was just like,
uh-huh?
Like, like like Lili Pichu and like Sykkuno, and I'm like, mhm.
And then...
So I'm just like, because she's like, younger, she doesn't, like, she's like the dance teacher is a lot younger, and because she's a lot younger, she doesn't know, like, like she obviously is more, she knows Twitch, and so she's like, do you stream on Twitch?
I was like, no, I don't stream on Twitch, I'm a YouTuber.
And then that was like the most I gave her, like...
Oh my god.
Anyway, so yeah, um, I hope I can get my dance lessons today, because like, it's today and tomorrow, and then like, it's trying to hope to God everything goes okay.
Okay.
Sadly, I don't know where the other dance teacher lives, because like, I know where the one that accidentally doxxed myself lived, because I was doing dance lessons at her place.
So the daughter of the dance teacher, just remember, we gotta keep each other safe.
We gotta keep each other safe.
We have a little agreement here.
Doxxing is a no-no.
You gotta learn.
No doxxing.
Anyway, um, it was fun.
Um, I think like, definitely, I think I might message Wolfie this, but like, for rookies, like, oh my god.
Like, the only, I think like, I did really well this time around, because um, like, I just need to play it once, and then I figure it out.
Like, I need to play the games like, once, and then everything just clicks for me.
Because I remember like, I was so bad at aiming, and I was so bad at like, the parkour and the races and everything.
And then, and the first time I played it, and then here, I actually figured it out so fast.
I was just like, oh okay, like, I've done this before, so I was just like, like, in my head, I was just like, bam.
Um, it was easier.
And, uh, but then like, oh my god, that course, the, that, the fucking, what was it?
The different parkours, um, the different parkour, and the trident, like, that shit like, not pissed me off, but like, it was so difficult.
Because like, I don't know the mechanics of it, especially for like, beginners.
And then the inter, the intermediates were so difficult.
Cause like, like, Wolfie was like, oh yeah, we lowered the, the difficulty level for, yeah, it was very frustrating.
Very frustrating.
And I felt like, um, I felt like, um, a lot of the mechanics were like, it was, like, the intermediate was so hard.
Like, when Wolfie was like, yeah, we lowered the difficulty for it.
And I was like, what?
I did the intermediate?
No, you should be able to do intermediate.
And I was trying to do it, I was like, what the fuck?
This is, this was a lower difficulty?
Like, like, it was like, beginner, and then the fucking difficulty scaled to like an 8.
I was just like, and I just felt like, I felt like I might, like, I feel like for rookies that was so difficult to play in general for rookies.
I think there was some, I think, also cause like, you know, like I said, I played it before, so like, it was very easy for me to like, have things click in place.
Um, yeah.
Um, and like, I never, I don't do Trident stuff, like I never used a Trident in actual normal Minecraft, so um, so it was all about like, things you have to, you have to have knowledge before to be able to do correctly.
Um, yeah, yeah, it was like, I was just like so confused and everything, but I think that definitely for rookies needs to have a lower difficulty or like, a place for people to practice or something, or just like, a video.
Like, just something that tells you what to do for each section cause like, I was so, I was so confused for each section.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I'm happy I did pretty well.
I think like, if I had points, I think if like, we had points from the first game, we would have definitely been like, top 15.
Like, we had no points from the first game, so um, um, and like, I had so much loot on me.
I had so much loot on me, and I think if I had, like, if I like, deposited all my loot, I would have been 15th place at least, at most, for the, from the first game.
And we did pretty well, 5th place for not having the first game points.
Uh, and I was fucking gaming today.
I was gaming, and I I locked in, and I was trying very hard to make friends, and I tried my best.
I tried.
Social anxiety didn't win today.
Yes, I I out anxiety'd social anxiety.
I out anxiety'd social anxiety.
We did it, guys.
I Um, also cause there was a lot of people.
I break down when there's too many people.
Like, if it's three of us, like, I don't know if some of you guys are like, oh, but like, you're able to make new friends if it's like, like, a smaller Yeah, I could do okay in a smaller group.
Cause then, like, we're all new and then we're like, like, we're all slowly getting to know each other, but there was like, five of us, and I was just like, that's a lot of people.
That's a lot of, there's a lot of people to, to, to, to talk to.
What makes you nervous?
It's not who, it's more so, it's like, I don't know any of them very well.
Like, I think like, Demi and Line, very first time I talked to them.
Hakka, I've only talked to him during the WrestleTubers stuff, was the only time I've ever talked to him.
And even then, like, it was like, I was a caster, so, there wasn't really much, like, actual talking to, and I never really got a chance to actually know him.
And then, like, Wolfie, only during that Block Wars session, like, last Block Wars session that I've talked to him.
So, it was like, it was like, like, because there was so much, like, uncertainty and stuff, so it was like, harder for me, personally, to, to, like, not, I don't want to say open up, but it's more so, like, just, like, be more of, you know, faking the extroversion.
Like, being, like, an extrovert at that time.
You know?
I'm just so used to, yeah, I fake it till you make it.
That's basically me.
I'm a full-on, I'm a full-on introvert.
And that's why I was like, you guys are, like, you're, like, emotional support animal.
You guys are, like, my emotional support animal, and that's why I was, like, muting to talk to you guys, just so I get, like, less anxious about, uh, talking to people.
Because, like, I'm talking to you guys and it's, like, there's, like, it's not, like, a void, but, like, um, you guys are just absorbing what I say and, like, uh, I can choose not to, I choose not to accept what you say.
No, I'm joking.
I could just look away.
You guys are my emotional support dragoons, and, like, I could just look away.
No, emotional support dragoons!
So it's easier to just when the void talks back.
When you give me feedback that I don't like, I could be, like...
I close my eyes.
When you tell me things that I know is right but I refuse to accept it, I just go...
Um, but, like I said, it's, like, easier to talk to you guys, because, like, it's just easier versus, like, some people that, like, one-on-one interactions.
And, like, I definitely feel much more comfortable.
Also, I can talk.
Also, by the way, you guys were wondering, like, Doki, why are you still here?
Like, I'll just stop moving.
I'm sorry.
I'm, like, I like to move.
I should be here.
I'm just so...
I'm just really, really...
Oh my gosh, I'm just more used to talking to people in a smaller group.
Alright, let me double-check my text messages.
Oh...
Oh, no!
Dance teacher is super busy today.
She's super busy.
So, I have dance lessons tomorrow.
Tomorrow...
It's gonna be a three-plus hour or four-plus hour session.
So, I have time with you guys before my next stream.
Yeah...
It was my fault, though.
I overbooked myself.
I overbooked myself and, like, I didn't time it correctly.
I didn't time the stuff correctly.
So, it is what it is.
It's a lesson.
I shouldn't have overbooked myself today or...
Cause, like, that was the only time slot for her.
And I was like, oh, I can make it, but I didn't time it correctly.
So, it's just like...
It's a lesson to me.
Um...
Gabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Makimo over here, thank you for the super chat.
What else?
I can actually read super chats now.
Oh my god.
Okay, uh... Chester, thank you for favorite super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Rest in peace, Doki.
Died when her social battery fell to zero after two plus weeks of doing stuff.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have a lot of energy in general.
Um... It's just like...
Like, it's always funny that people don't know that I have a lot of introvertism.
Every time I tell people, like, yeah, I'm an introvert.
Like, people are like, what?
People...
don't know that I'm actually a huge introvert.
Also, didn't we get fifth place?
I thought we got fifth overall.
Haka, like, fucking added us and was like, we got fourth.
I'm pretty sure we were fifth.
Oh, I won't tell him that.
I don't want...
He thinks we got fourth place, guys.
Don't break his spirit.
Don't let him believe it.
Don't ruin his dreams, guys.
Oh, that's neat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
For a while, I was convinced I couldn't make it to the Phantom Thief concert.
But I was able to shift things around.
Now I'm going.
I'm so excited to support you and me and the other guests.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I'm super excited.
I'm so nervous for the concert.
It's gonna be my first concert.
Not my first recording, but my first concert.
I'm always really nervous about the dance because I've had less prep time regarding dance lessons for this one.
But I have more songs.
So...
Whoa!
So I'm super nervous.
That's why I've been grinding really hard on the lessons.
Because I really want you guys to have a really good time watching.
So I've been grinding really hard on the lessons.
I know I shouldn't overdo it, but I want you guys to have...
Because you're paying so much to...
You guys are paying so much to to come to the concert, especially because there's no streaming tickets too.
So I want those who are able to make it to have a really good time.
But we are gonna upload the individual performances as well to the individual performances on YouTube.
Not all of them, but two of them.
We'll have two of them that we'll upload on our end.
So people who weren't able to make it will at least see two of the individual performances that Mint and I are gonna upload.
So she'll have one on her channel and I'll have one on my channel.
So there's that.
Oh my gosh, it's so stressful.
Dance lessons is so stressful because it's like... I don't dance, but I want to improve if I get... I don't know.
I also don't know if I'll ever get another chance to do concerts too.
It's like, you know, I'm not...
My dance teacher keeps...
Okay, so like the one I doxed myself to, she was like, I was listening to you singing and you sing so well.
And I was like, that's not true.
That's not true.
I've seen people on the internet call my singing...
I'm just like thinking no, even if they're not... I've seen people on the internet
call my singing and I was like, you know what, I'm not singing.
I'm just...
I'm just like, no, don't say that.
Don't say that.
Nali, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
We're not real, we're just voices.
You have to take them before the men in white come back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mr. Brokenbon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for all your hard work done, Doki.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
TastyDiaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, big ass boy, will you release your keycaps set in an alternative dark mode?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If you buy all the stock, we can consider it.
It depends on, like, if there's...
Okay, not you individually.
I'm not asking you to spend all your money to buy the entire remaining stock of the merch.
By the way, they're talking about, um...
The Hyatt stuff is now in stock.
So those who haven't pre-ordered...
And were thinking about buying it, you can now...
Um...
Grab the collection.
But, like, really, it depends on if we'll have, like, more...
More...
If Hyatt and I work together more, it's mostly...
Um...
Okay, wait.
In stock now.
Uh...
For custom PC cases, keycaps, etc.
Um...
Maybe I'll put it up here, too.
Might as well.
It's shilling time.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Here.
Ha ha ha!
It's shilling time!
Um...
Uh...
Also, I miss just talking to you guys, you know?
I miss just being able to hang out and talk to you guys.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Uh...
And, like...
We'd be able to make more...
Oh my gosh, maybe not there, because now you guys can't use the QR code.
Uh...
Make more...
Obviously, work together more if, uh, you know...
All the stock is sold out and, like, there's a demand for it.
So it's more of...
More...
But, like...
If there's a demand for it, then, obviously, we would work together more on stock.
Ha ha ha ha!
Um...
Alan, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I'll be able to make another amazing concert in the future, as much as I want to go.
It's literally impossible for me to go this year.
I can't even throw money at this problem!
Good luck though!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, I hope...
I hope so.
I hope I get another opportunity in the future.
I'm trying not to take things for granted right now.
And, like...
It's why I'm going, like, fast, fast, fast on all things.
I think, like...
I know I'm really lucky to be fortunate to be in the position I am in.
Like, I'll let you guys know this.
The amount of money I've made since coming back...
Has been...
More than what I've ever made before.
And much more.
So it's like...
And I don't even have merch.
That's the thing.
That's the craziest thing to me.
I don't even have, like, actual merch sales right now.
Because I'm, like, fixing all the stuff that's going on.
I, like...
I don't even have merch sales going on anymore.
Because, like, I'm trying to fix everything.
Well...
I'm not saying profit-wise.
Because I spent a lot, too.
I also spent a lot.
Because I'm making more.
I also spent a lot more.
And also, I moved and everything.
And also, I'm doing, like, dance lessons.
And also, that and that.
And there's, like, a lot of things going on as well.
So, like...
I don't know, like, profit-wise.
What it is.
Like, at the moment.
I don't know what the profit is at the moment.
Because, like, I haven't calculated anything.
Um...
So, like...
It's, like...
I'm trying not to take things for granted.
So, I'm trying to, like...
I know everything is happening super fast right now.
But, like, I don't know if I'll have another...
Like...
If this year...
After this year...
Um...
It's gonna be...
Like, it would be the same.
Like...
So, that's also why I'm, like...
Saying yes to a lot of opportunities.
And...
Um...
Yeah, I'm also, like...
I have to think about taxes, too.
But I'm also saying yes to a lot of opportunities.
Saying yes to a lot of, like...
Things that are being offered to me.
Like, this Minecraft thing.
I thought, like, it'd be nice to meet new people.
Even though I'm, like, super anxious and everything.
Um...
And, like...
Uh...
Try my best to...
Talk to people, which is very hard.
And...
Uh...
And just, like, try my best to be...
To, like...
Uh...
You know...
Meet new people and stuff.
And do new opportunities.
Do things I haven't done before.
Um...
And do a lot of conventions.
Because I never had a chance to do a lot of conventions, too.
So...
Um...
It's, like...
I- That's why I'm going...
I feel like you guys are, like...
When will she stop...
When will she stop getting these Ws?
And then I'm just, like...
I'm just, like...
There's a lot of stuff coming in.
I know...
Dragoons are not used to this.
Dragoons are, like...
Not used to having so many, like...
Announcements.
Back to back to back to back.
And...
It's, like...
It feels like every week...
Like, there's something...
Every week, there's, like...
Something new happening.
And I hope you guys...
I really hope you guys...
Aren't overdosing on it.
I like the way you laugh.
Thank you!
I'm glad.
But yeah.
I just want you guys to be able to enjoy the moment.
Especially, like...
You know, everything you guys have all been through.
And you guys have...
Still here after everything.
Which is...
Which really means a lot.
It was, like, my biggest worry.
I was just, like...
After coming back as Indie, I was just, like...
Oh my god, like...
It was just, like...
What do I do?
Like...
Can I still do this?
I'm just, like...
Oh my god.
Can I still do this?
Like, what's gonna be...
Will I even be able to, like...
Do anything?
Am I, like, blacklisted?
So...
I really do...
Appreciate it, guys.
Also, speaking of, like...
VTuber stuff.
I heard the VTuber award nominations are out now.
I really...
Like, appreciate...
I think this is, like, the one thing I would really like.
I think I...
Did I write that in my goals list?
But...
Chilling Time Part 2.
So...
Nominations are now up.
I would love to be nominated...
For FPS and Gamer of the Year.
Alright, so the VTuber awards are back.
And, like...
Honestly...
I don't really...
Ask...
I don't feel like I ask for things.
But, like...
Low-key...
I would really like to be nominated...
As FPS and Gamer of the Year.
Just cause, like...
It's sort of, like...
I just want my...
Me on there.
I'm trying to, like, word this...
Properly, you know?
Cause if you look at 2023...
I'm, like...
But...
So, I'm just, like...
I just want, like...
2024, like...
Joke-keeper.
It's really...
I just want that to...
Not your replace.
That's a better...
That's a better word.
I want that to replace.
So, it's like...
It's sort of, like, the last...
I guess, like...
Part...
Of...
History that I want, like, a good...
A good memory of.
I mean, it's still a good memory.
It just sucks when I look at 2023 winners.
It's just...
Like, okay, to be true...
It still...
It does suck.
Like, when I see 2023 winners...
And I see...
I was, like...
I just want, like, in 2024...
Just, like, you know...
My joke-keeper on there instead.
Like...
Especially my fucking acceptance speech.
I...
I take it back.
Let's see.
Riz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't care what these people say.
Yusan, Doxan, Sanastro, I can say you sing.
You can sing!
Toki, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's why I was, like...
I really want to be nominated.
Because I want, like...
Happier memories.
I want happier memories of it.
To overwrite it.
That's why I really want to be nominated.
No, I do ask for a lot.
I'll be like, subscribe to me!
Buy my...
JK, I do ask for a lot.
But I'll ask for a little bit more.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you never stop getting those Ws.
It's so exciting.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, did I show you guys the snapshot for the...
I did, but I'll show you guys the final design we went with.
For the Lunar New Year snapshots.
I'm so excited for next year.
When we can actually do merch.
Because merch design is something...
I have an entire folder of stuff I want to do for merch.
And it's like...
I just want to...
I just...
I just cannot wait until all of that fucking shit is fixed.
It's like...
We're so close.
It's practically fixed now.
But we're doing a trial run with our new distributor.
And it should be shipped by...
The stuff that...
Well, the old distributor is shipping the remaining products from the old merch.
But the new merch that...
Like the acrylic stand.
The Bounty Hunter acrylic stand is being done by our new distributor.
That's gonna be finished.
That should be shipped by December.
For the new Bounty Hunter acrylic stand.
By the way, we upgraded the acrylic stand.
Because you guys waited so much.
So long.
So I asked them to upgrade the whole entire thing.
So it's gonna be like a diorama acrylic stand now.
So just so you guys know.
So it's like super upgraded and stuff.
Just because you guys waited so long for it.
And I asked for like an upgrade to make it like...
Better.
Just for those who waited for so long.
Anyway.
Anyway, here is...
Also, it's so nice to just talk to you guys.
I haven't done that in a long time.
But I don't have to fucking go to dance lessons.
It sucks that I can't go to dance lessons.
But like...
At least I can actually...
Zazz it on.
Anyway.
So this is the front of it.
By the way, please don't...
Please don't illegally download this.
Like...
Don't illegally download...
You won't illegally download this, right?
Anyway.
And then this is the...
Oh shit.
Okay.
This is the back side of the snapshot.
So this is a regular bundle.
So this is the snapshot of...
You know, like...
You put it in like a snapshot sleeve.
And then this is what...
This is what it looks like.
I thought it was really cute.
How it...
How it's design and everything.
I think it's...
Alright.
Now you guys are making me paranoid.
I'm making it smaller.
I'm making it smaller now.
Now you're making me paranoid.
This is the...
I'm making it even smaller now.
The back side and the front side of the...
The photo.
I guess you can call it the photo card.
Okay.
The fucking quality.
Okay, now...
We can't have nice things anymore.
But it's...
It's too late.
Please.
Please don't...
Don't steal it.
Please.
But...
But it's really cute.
And I'm super happy about it.
I'm just like...
There's so many things going on.
I'm so happy.
But yeah.
There's...
For those who don't know.
Also like...
Doobie is going...
Coming to my...
Coming to our 3D concert.
Doobie.
Doobie is such a fucking funny name.
Like I'm gonna doob.
I'm doobing.
Tomorrow is my birthday.
So here's $20.
Oli, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Oli.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I really...
I really appreciate it.
It's your birthday.
And you're paying me money.
Let's see.
John Lacone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You better believe we'd be in it for the long haul.
Trust in us.
We trust in you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gio, so glad you have a lot of opportunities now.
And you're having fun too.
We're going up and out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
AK.
Dragoons are ride or die.
Doki Bird 2.
Moon and beyond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, did I show you one of the merch I'm making?
I'm gonna spoil it.
I have like a lot of...
Oh, shit.
This is not the person.
Oh, my God.
I typed in a different...
That was not the person I wanted to...
Wait, what's this person's name?
Uh...
Oh, fuck.
What is this person's name?
I want to show you guys.
Did I show you guys the coin I'm making?
I did, right?
No, I did.
I showed you guys.
It's not even a spoiler.
I already showed you guys the coin.
I remember now.
I showed you guys what it looks like.
Yeah.
Yeah, the Doki coin.
Didn't I show you guys?
Did I show you guys what it's gonna look like?
Did I show you guys what it's gonna look like, though?
I don't remember.
I did?
Okay, I'll show you guys another...
I'll show you guys a more refined version.
You guys can't steal this one because like, uh...
It's unstealable.
Okay, so it's this.
Uh, no, it's not fucking crypto.
This is the front of the coin.
I think crypto's dead now, isn't it?
And this is the... this is the back of it.
I won't be surprised if someone makes a V2 rare crypto coin.
I would not be surprised.
Uh, but yeah!
Uh, this is the... this is the Doki coin that I'm working on, too.
Um, obviously we're fixing our merch issue before we fucking do all of this.
Hahahahaha!
Um, but yeah!
This is the Doki coin that I'm, uh...
Um, it's like those, like, actual coins.
Like, those, like, um...
With, like, the textures and stuff.
So, I'm, like, I don't know how to explain it.
Like, those medallion coins.
Uh, like, you see sometimes the little indent texture.
Like, the dark gold is, like, a special texture and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
So, that's basically...
I think I asked for corrections on this a little bit, but I don't remember.
I don't remember.
I'll figure it out later, but...
Hahahahaha!
Um, but yeah, I'm super excited.
There's, like, so many plans for things.
And I'm, like, yay!
I just hope everything goes okay.
And, like, I hope, like, next year will...
Might not be, like, as...
It might not have, like, as many opportunities as this year.
But, like, I hope that next year will be okay.
I hope next year Doki will...
Will, like, still be okay.
And can still do the things she wants to do.
Hahahahaha!
Oh yeah, I'm releasing new anima...
I'm releasing free animated stickers today.
So, I'll post that on Twitter, on the YouTube community post about that.
Uh, so, uh, for those who were...
Wanted to...
Uh, for those who aren't able to afford the line stickers.
Also, I was so surprised at the amount of people that bought it.
Like, I know, I...
I thought, I was not...
I made it not thinking that I was not going to make a profit off of it.
I just thought it would be really cute for you guys.
For you guys to use.
That's a lot of my ideas.
It's more so of, like...
I just think the idea...
Like, I just like doing them.
Just because I think it will be...
You guys will enjoy it.
And I don't go in for profit.
I just think, like, oh, you guys are going to enjoy it.
So, like, uh, like...
Um, I don't really think about, like, profit wise when I do these types of things.
So, I was really surprised that we're almost...
Because, like, it's an animated sticker.
So, it was, like, really expensive.
Just because, like, there's, like, 16 of it.
There's 16 of it.
And it was, like, you know, um...
Hubion is, like, an amazing artist.
And, um, they worked really hard on, like, creating all of it.
So, like, honestly, I went in thinking it would be, like, in the red when it comes to, like...
Will I make back the money?
Um...
And we actually almost broke even.
Which I was very surprised about.
I was not expecting us to, like, almost break even on it.
So...
That's a nice surprise.
That's a...
It's just, you know, it's nice when things work out.
Marco, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I only started watching you and other VTubers in general around February, but I'm proud to call you my Kamiyoshi now.
Oh, thank you, Marco!
Keep on being you, Doki.
Thank you.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Solid, thank you for the superchat.
One day I'll be able to get some of that cute Doki merch.
Marco Edwards, until then, damn you, Latin America curse.
Keep being awesome.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
My financially responsible Oshii is in the black!
Yippee!
Thank you for the superchat, Johnny.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here.
I have a member stream in two hours.
I don't remember what time I set up.
I have a member stream and then I have Kami Furou today.
So, uh...
I was supposed to rest my voice, but I ended up fucking...
I don't know, I haven't had a chance to talk to you guys in a long time, so I was just like...
I just kept yapping.
I had so much energy because I drank GamerSup today.
Anyway, you guys didn't know, I have a GamerSup code.
It's DokiBird and you can get 10% off.
I don't know when the GamerSup stuff is gonna be out.
We were talking about...
I was talking to GamerSup about when to release the items.
I don't know if it's gonna be this month.
I think it might be this month.
So, I'll talk to them again about it.
I think pre-orders are gonna be this month.
Because they were thinking about pushing it to another month.
And I was like, oh, I think it would be better if pre-orders were up earlier.
Just because...
Because a lot of GamerSup stuff is being released around the same time.
For this month.
So they were worried that they might overlap and stuff.
And I was like, don't worry, my Dragoons will buy my stuff.
Because it's only gonna be out for pre-orders for two weeks, by the way.
It's only gonna be out for two weeks for the GamerSup stuff, when my stuff comes out.
And I'll let you guys know now.
The amount of pre-orders that the GamerSup is gonna get...
Will determine if I'm gonna get a flavor.
Nudge nudge.
I wonder what that means.
Um...
Very subtle, Doki.
It's just...
It's just business.
She does ask for a lot.
I mean, like...
It really depends on you guys.
If you guys don't want a flavor, that's fine by me.
If you guys don't...
It's like, oh, you guys want a flavor, then you know what to do.
I don't...
If you guys don't want it, then don't buy it.
We do want it.
Yeah, so now it's our fault.
I'm sorry.
Okay, how about this?
I'll also buy, like, 30.
How about that?
I'll buy, like, 30 of my cups.
Is that what you want me to say?
Yeah.
Guys, finally, physical Doki.
Thank you.
I'll just, like, invest.
Isn't that, like, illegal?
Like, not buying your...
Wait, okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Any flavor ideas?
I have no idea.
I don't even know if I'm going to get it.
But, like, I know, like, people do that.
So...
On Amazon Books...
For Amazon Books, they would...
People would buy their own books.
For Amazon.
So they can pump up their own rankings.
So they'll show up as, like, a number one bestseller on Amazon.
If they buy, like, a lot of their own books.
Like, people actually do that.
Which is crazy to think about.
Anyway...
I'm not...
I'm not going to say if I'm going to do it or not.
But I'll put the idea in your head.
I'll put the idea...
I'll put the...
I'll put the idea in your head.
Ehhhhhh...
Um...
Gamersubs bestseller chart topic.
Anyway.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to call it here, everybody.
As always, everyone.
It was very, really nice talking to you guys and hanging out again.
Because I don't have a chance to do that a lot these days.
Just cause how busy I am.
So it's really nice to just talk and hang out with my dragoons and um I'm gonna be gone for a while next week.
I'm gonna do an off collab with mint on her channel I don't know if i'm gonna do one on my channel because like we don't have a lot of time together so like The last time we did an off collab together.
It was on my channel that doesn't exist anymore.
Um I don't know what happened to that vod Oh But like so like it's her turn, you know, so um, so like, uh, it's her turn now so but I don't know if i'll have the Energy, uh to do a second off collab because I know we're both really busy.
So we'll see we'll see we'll see if like she uh If she wants to do a second one, but I know we're I know when we're doing a first one Like the first one together for next week, um Um, and yeah, it's gonna be on her channel Um, i'll see if we'll be able to do a second one And i'll definitely do try and do a gorilla rest stream tomorrow and like on one of the days i'll um on one on my laptop,
okay tomorrow on my pc and then uh When i'm away in can away from canada I'll try to gorilla rest stream for the drops and stuff because like, uh, you know I feel bad not being able to do it a lot because of the timing and stuff and like, you know I'm,
really thankful for abe and saikuno for letting me Get to have a chance to experience it.
Uh, so yeah, uh, I will try my best to do a gorilla rest stream while i'm out of country Um before the event ends for people who are want the drops people who haven't got a chance Uh to get the the ak drops yet Uh, because I know a lot of people haven't had a chance to and I didn't stream that much of rest.
Um, anyway Oh, let's go.
Thank you.
Let's super chat.
We're going into debt with this one Thank you super chat.
Yeah, i'm going to america i'm going to the states I haven't I rarely ever visit america Um, I don't even remember the last time I was there.
I don't even remember.
It's been so long.
Um, anyway, uh, anyway guys Uh, I got the drop so you don't have to Sorry guys, uh yo-yo's already got it.
So like I guess these streams cancel
Hey guys for real though, uh, uh, as always everybody say hydrated posse Check it up and move around to get that blood flowing and you say it for me Or if you're a member don't head to bed yet Because we have another stream later on two hours or head to bed because you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye You